there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock any people episode 100 79
yeah we're doing up there huh
yeah we're gonna have the 200th one like
sometime this year yeah I thought maybe
maybe we should do a live stream Oh
several people have asked us about doing
a live stream for the 200th show yeah
they're asking so maybe we should do
that I mean that's still like a couple
months off but we don't quite have the
amount of subscribers that you need to
do that successfully but we could try it
well we'll see I mean we just recently
got over the 8,000 subscriber mark on
YouTube so it was very exciting
yes so this show this is kind of like I
can't remember if this was something
it's kind of a combination of something
you suggested and something that someone
suggested a long time ago this is gonna
be just kind of like a grab-bag type of
show titled mysteries of ancient Rome
yeah like I think somebody asked me
about doing lucasta
the ancient Roman poisoner considered
the first serial killer at least the
first female serial killer so I wanted
to talk about her and then there was
just like other stuff that I thought was
interesting that I came across during my
reading like various weird
archaeological finds weird mass graves
villa the mysteries in Pompeii like all
that kind of stuff so we're just gonna
be talking about that in our usual
random aimless slightly drunken sort of
way yeah I'm pretty I'm pretty familiar
with Rome I read a decline and fall of
the Empire yeah that the long version
though it's like three huge [ __ ]
Tom's yeah that was talking difficult to
get through it
history does repeat itself and of course
you can't remember all the names yeah
and
everybody kind of does the same thing
over and over and over again you know
well people have a certain parameters
right that in in a given situation
there's only like a B C and D yeah and
only the results you're gonna get and
really only the Great's would stand out
you know guys like Commodus and [ __ ]
like that
I was calling like a commode they
emptied out his palace and found a bunch
of damn sex slaves in there a lot of
them Royals thank you yeah which is
illegal they were doing all kind of
keeping them as slaves and stuff you
know oh yeah
but yeah so we'll get into that in a
little bit first
though we're gonna do a couple shout
outs as I said if you've noticed like it
does seem to be like more popular than I
thought but my witching hour stories
that I read that I've been putting up
every Thursday people seem to be really
liking those and I'm kind of jacked
about it so it's like so those will keep
coming up every Thursday and thanks for
everybody that has sent me messages and
stuff like that about how cool they
think it is because I thought it was
kind of cool to do also I would like to
thank our newest patron whose name is
Dominic yeah kind of there thank God my
roller there yes
$20 a month appreciate it dude yeah it's
very much appreciated yeah also I would
like to thank one of our who had already
been a $20 and $20 patron liam he
actually sent me a donation on paypal to
cover the shipping for the t-shirt
that's at we sent him and I was like oh
man you don't have to do that but he did
it anyway and that is really obvious I
guess everybody got their t-shirts I
guess so like I've only heard from a
couple people that got him my day I have
to send one more out yeah we have to
make one more okay so whenever I go out
and get sure cuz actually we could
probably just get the shirt while we're
outside of ordering it because then it
won't like take as long um but yeah so I
seem to be satisfied uh yeah it seems
like most of the couple messages I got
were very positive so you know I thought
they came out cool I thought they did
yeah you know
saying someone the design everything but
yeah I thought they came out pretty cool
did you want to show off your new little
robot there oh yeah yeah great mazinger
yeah this is the this is the latest
addition to your collection
yeah it's diecast metal ya know from
Japan Bandai this is part of the new I
think it's called a dynamic classic
collection which I really liked this
this sculpt because I know where they
got this go
they got this sculpt they ripped this
off my buddy jammie who owns another
company that does this call HL Pro yeah
he owns a tail Pro and they were coming
out with it's a long story but this
particular kind of sculpt which is kind
of more elongated he was doing it with
his enemy robots which I got some up
there he and Bandai which is a huge
company huge corporation copied him yeah
something he was furious maybe I
shouldn't have said industrial yeah I
still like my bad guys work man is
really good and it's of course this is
all fully articulated it come with a
bunch of stuff these are expensive these
I got it on sale it was about 115 bucks
on sale but sometimes I splurge and buy
I want but now I just grew up with them
you know I was had these things since I
was a kid by the seventies how are
people by DJ I think I told people about
that crazy Japanese cartoons I grew up
watching yeah I think yeah I think a lot
of people are who I wasn't familiar with
I'm like I became familiar with them
after you told me begin to get a robo G
and grand Iser
yeah yeah but well didn't they dub some
of them into English did they not
yeah they mash them up made kind of like
bastardized versions of the originals
yeah and then they can't Bandai dumped
down a lot of its toys or some of its
select toys and then entered it into a
deal with Mattel and they released him
into Shogun warrior yeah yeah okay I
remembered those I had a lot of those
yeah they were good but the Japanese
versions were a lot better yeah he came
with a lot more extra stuff and you know
like I got some of the big jumbo ones up
there and you know they came with like
mix mix match fists and stuff to give
them extra plate
playability and they didn't sell them
with like the wings like I got a great
mazinger up there and seen he came with
a little wings on the back a little jet
scrander is what they called it and the
big jumbo originally in Japan came with
those big wings but of course they
didn't sell those didn't sell them to us
because they thought you'll put your eye
out well we didn't know what the average
American kid didn't know what the
original character is supposed to look
like we didn't have a shows yeah so they
just gave us kind of dumbed down version
of them and they were only 20 bucks at
Jumbo's I think the Japanese original
versions in Japan were probably closer
to like 50 or 60 well they were much
nicer they were nice to the kid more
stuff because the kids knew they were
yeah so that you couldn't have step on
the Japanese kids they knew it they knew
what it's supposed to look like yeah so
become a big ol package of [ __ ] you know
[Laughter]
charge important talk to us have a
gigantic collection of all these robots
those are actually very nice though yeah
just try to most of them are diecast
metal you know it's one of them either
they have to be big or they have to be
that classic I guess metal one or two
yeah I think that's a big collection
that's like there's you know it's
several thousand dollars were very large
skull those are very rare
that's like much more than I've ever
spent on my the only thing that I
collect which is mystery sighs well you
know everybody's got to have something
and I mean you should probably buy some
more MST stuff well I don't really have
the extra money to buy Ivy I do like
avenues I do like haven't I have most of
the episodes but a couple um I buy the
box sets you know that shout factory
puts out but I stopped buying them like
several like a couple years ago just cuz
I can because I didn't have the extra
money to buy them like every time they
came out because they would put out like
two or three-year and they're like 50 or
$60 and I was just like holy crap man I
can't afford all that like I can't
afford to keep up I do have all of the
episodes on that were burned like to you
know to DVD that I got
off the what the [ __ ] did they used to
call that thing where you could get all
the episodes for free they don't offer
all of them anymore just because they
don't want to step on shout factories
dick but I think I got pretty much every
episode through there they're not great
quality because obviously they were just
taped off TV and then burn to DVD but
you know they're good to have for just
like playing in the background or
something like that so they're not like
super high quality and they don't have
all the extras and [ __ ] on there but um
you know I do try to get the you know I
do try to get the box that's when I have
extra money but you know that's not
usually so you should have said some out
of body something I can't even I don't
even remember how many I've missed out
on yeah you know what I mean like I
don't know how behind I am on it cuz
they like I said they release like at
least one or two a year have you said
something Ida body song I phrase I
forgot about it yeah well because yeah
yeah yeah alright so like I said this is
kind of like a grab bag show of just
[ __ ] that I thought was interesting and
like I said you can throw in [ __ ] if you
think of anything interesting that you
find fascinating also so like is not a
huge plan about perm going with this but
the first thing I want to talk about
this is kind of like a brief news story
that I came across this is from early
2017 and the the title of the article
was the man with the stone tongue now
this was from a Roman Britain burial
site in Northamptonshire specifically in
Stanwyck and they found a skeleton of a
dude whose tongue had been cut out and
then like replaced with a stone like
before they buried him like they put a
stone in his mouth where his tongue was
and then other weird thing too is that
he was also buried facedown now they
didn't they have found like you know
other bodies that were buried facedown
in Roman Britain burial sites however
the amputated tongue and the stone in
place of the tongue is as far as they
know a completely unique mutilation and
they're not entirely sure what it
signifies it was a [ __ ] liar probably
well they they did consider that they
said okay well here's where it could be
this
now the fact that he was buried facedown
that is usually an indicator that this
was a person who they thought was a
threat either because they were crazy or
they were like super mean or something
like that and they would bury them
facedown presumably so their corpse
wouldn't like come back and get people
because I guess if they tried to dig
their way out they just dig their way
further down but they do have like other
examples of that where bodies were
buried facedown and it was always like
some crazy [ __ ] or like a me and
[ __ ] yeah he was probably some
contractors dude that lied so chaos
something like that probably yes so it
might be something of that nature now
they said alternately this could be a
crazy guy who cut off his own tongue for
some reason although they are kind of
running with the theory that probably
this was done to him you know as a
specific type of punishment like you
said no no I was alive um it likely
because the guide the archaeologist I
think his name is Simon Mays the
archaeologist who studied the skeleton
said that they found like a lot of
evidence of infection like in the bones
and they said now if you cut a tongue
out you're gonna get infected because
there's so much bacteria and [ __ ] like
that in the human mouth that it's gonna
get in there and he's like so we did
find evidence of a lot of infection like
in evidence of infection and the guy's
bones and stuff so they did figure that
it was cut off while he was still alive
like I said whether he did it or whether
someone else did it they're not entirely
sure what they were saying was
apparently in Germanic law there is a
thing where if you were for example
spreading malicious accusations against
people that was a known punishment that
they would cut your tongue out however
they're not entirely sure if there were
any laws to that effect in Roman Britain
they have not found anything of that
nature so farst they don't know if this
was like a legal kind of thing or
whatever now another interesting thing
too is they said like I said this is the
only one they found where it was a
tongue and it was like replaced with a
rock
they said however
they have found ten other burial sites
that had bodies in them that had a body
part removed and replaced with something
else like in the grave
they said usually it's decapitation like
they will cut the person's head off and
then they'll put like a big rock or a
big pot like where their head would be
like almost I don't know why that is
like just to be a [ __ ] you or whatever
and I'm not sure what they do with this
if they're just like that's kind of like
what Native Americans believed yeah that
if you miss we're missing a body part
and you went into the afterworld that
maybe you know I mean you'd be crippled
over there yeah that was another thing
that they had considered yeah right so
maybe they're just trying to give him a
substitute body part so he's whole yeah
but for some reason they turn him upside
down just yeah face down like I said
that and you know several archaeologists
said that implies that this was someone
who was a troublemaker or a criminal or
something like that because apparently
in other sites that they found where
people were buried face down like that
that's usually what that meant and they
speculate that it was because like I
said they didn't want the dude coming
back as a zombie when was this guy
buried more or less um they think it's
probably they think he was probably in
his 30s they said it's like probably
from the third or fourth century and
this Edie yeah and this is a Roman
Britain like I said yes still pretty
pre-christian really yeah very
agricultural area Christianity didn't
didn't take hold actually until hundreds
of years later more like 17th century
yeah that's really when you saw it
everywhere but I think what I think what
you're talking about you're talking
about something almost kind of like what
the ancient Egyptians would do you know
yeah if what the things removed they
didn't put it in a pot or Internet
someone's ancient Egyptians I guess but
they were just trying to be whole in the
afterlife
so yeah Bry kind of doing where the
guy's tongue was cut out for one reason
or another they didn't really like him
but they didn't want him to to be you
know in the afterlife forever you know
missing a tongue I thought that was that
would kind of set my Bello over
or something you know maybe so so he's
put a rock in his mouth instead of a
tongue so he'd have a tongue in heaven
yeah somebody that that's what um the
archaeologists like I said who was
working on this Simon Mays he actually
did say and this is a quote from the
article it says the whole idea of
replacing a severed body part with an
object is interesting in itself it could
be an attempt to complete an incomplete
body or it could be an attempt to
replace part of a body with something
obviously inanimate like a stone or pot
to prevent the corpse from being
complete now interestingly that this
particular skeleton was found all the
way back in 1991 however I guess there's
so much Roman [ __ ] laying around in like
England that it took this long liked to
have the manpower like all the
archaeologists to like finally get
around to looking into this because the
one cemetery was found apparently I had
35 bodies in it that they found as far
as I know this is the only one that had
anything weird about it so they're just
assuming that there was something about
this guy that made him he was dangerous
or mentally ill or something of that
nature because he his burial was
apparently different than any of the
other very way I'm looking at it think
about it think about this you're trying
to bury this guy you might know him
you're you get all he know him but his
head's gone yeah so you're laying him
out in front everybody else it's kind of
humiliating for him not to have a head
it's just not gonna look right so you
just put a pot there yeah to make it
look a little bit better look more
balanced well you trying to show him
some courtesy you know what an attempt
of trying to come giving him his head
back yeah
you know so they bury him like this
that's prolly some I'm gonna say I'm
Melea more towards that I wonder if they
like would draw a face on it or
something that would be really look
quite as weird you know especially if
you know you're around candle light
stuff that's true I do kind of wonder
though I wonder if any I don't think
that I've seen anything that said that
look that they dug up any that had a pot
that like a body if they found one that
was like cause they Frandsen [ __ ]
[ __ ] and like some Roman crates and
stuff and it's just like it'd be
horrible but also be kind of funny you
just got in here but I got him yeah
because we keep opening the doors let
the kiddies out on the porch so an
interrelated not really related but it's
like a similar kind of thing I found
this other article that came out in June
of 2018 and this was also in a Roman era
grave that was found in Cambridgeshire
except in this case there were two guys
and they were found with their legs
chopped off at the knees and placed
carefully by their shoulders before
burial so they their skulls were also
smashed in they don't know what these
guys did in particular to like piss
somebody off and they're not really sure
I mean it obviously it looks like the
legs were cut off when they were still
alive so it's almost like they were
trying to keep them from running away or
something I thought yeah it definitely
was a punishment yeah because this is
actually from the late Roman or early
Saxon period and the bodies were found
they were like at right angles to each
other and their heads were like turned
away from one another and where they
were found was a gravel pit which it was
not a cemetery it had been used as like
a garbage dump so so there's
archaeologists who's working on it said
and I quote somebody really really
didn't like yeah it's like we didn't
really find any human remains in this
area except for these two guys and then
they found another guy right like right
nearby who he was in it was like this
timber lined well and it had already
begun to fill in and then they found
another body in there that had been
chopped off at the waist like a guy that
was cut in half so they didn't find any
his pelvis they didn't find his leg
bones but his like the upper half of his
torso in his head were still intact and
it looks like they had just kind of
thrown him into this well like by this
garbage dump
yeah well they did it cost oh they did
yeah I mean I saw I saw like medieval
era
I saw a program about medieval era law
books that they found and had a lot of
drawings in him I don't remember if they
were German or if they were English I
think that might have been English you
should see how they practice law it was
a trip yeah there's been crazy [ __ ] yeah
if you had an argument with somebody but
basically was just a series of bunch of
controlled duels and you know like a
duel between a man and a woman you know
you wouldn't think they did that they
did that and they would take the guy and
Barry put him um was it in the ground
yeah get ahold they put him in a hole to
handicap over to handicap him and gave
him a certain kind of weapon he could
barely reach her and then she stood
above him but she was staked to the
ground you know with like a chain on
runner yeah and they're trying to make
it fair yeah yeah obviously put a lot of
thought yeah and like he would have a
shield but she could have like a like a
hammer it wouldn't give anybody swords
because that was kind of like a weapon
of nobility cheating no it was a weapon
of nobility that could happen and it was
weird they were dueling with shields too
and they had a whole variety of weapons
that just people don't even know about
this is a medieval era it was a shield
that was shaped like a boat that had a
bike's on the front and then blades on
the end and they said that they had
skilled skilled fighters that preferred
that to sword and they would just kill
each other with shields huh because they
would give those to peasants to settle
[ __ ] because as a peasant could have a
shield yeah it wasn't technically or
legally a weapon you guys blood you can
put blades on it though yeah and it was
still my god well you know it's coming
here any nonstick god laws here in the
United States don't quite make sense you
know you can't have a bayonet logo on it
oh my god terrible you know you have an
8k view scan of a bayonet log on it
that's like you're gonna go ahead and
kill people with bayonets because you
gotta maintain your yeah well when you
run a bullhead said you can just go look
you just have a knife though it doesn't
deal with spirit doesn't make it any
more deadly they wanted you know you
could have it I think all that's gone
now but I'm gonna think about a shield
that's like you could pretty easily I
mean you could probably pretty easily
knock somebody out and beat him to death
wait hang put a spike on the front and
spikes on the ends I hit a Nelson you
can think you can control it like this
it was just man it was a commis there's
a well there is a weaponized shield yeah
yeah I mean to get around those damn
sword control laws I do not write
writing on it right you know in pet and
the peasant could own it so they were
doing the whole history of the world
it's just like everything is loopholes
yeah everything's [ __ ] loopholes
because everything can be worked
that's why suckers and sad sacks today
depending on them they think all this
all the problems are gonna be solved by
some con [ __ ] government they will
never saw your problems they will make
more problems there will always be
loopholes well like I said pretty much
everything can be worked around
repeating his work around everything
especially you did we're talking about
Americans three people in the UK maybe
you're not aware of this but Americans
[ __ ] cheat well duh yeah cheap for a
[ __ ] living okay
it doesn't matter what laws you give us
we're gonna find a way around yeah
there's only one people of the world
that's better at it than Americans
Brazilian you can pass anything any law
you why in Brazil it's not gonna [ __ ]
go yeah we don't like we'd rather not
that's why I got a big respect they know
when to call [ __ ] we're not gonna do
that
oh yeah so apparently these the graves
of these three unfortunate dudes maybe
they weren't unfortunate maybe they were
criminals and they deserved it I don't
really
some illegal law system did but they
were found like during I guess it was
like um a highway I think it was the a
24 or something like that was being like
widened in camera sure and they found
like a whole bunch of like room and era
stuff in there as far as I know they
found some human remains these were like
the main three bodies that they found
they did find a bunch of pottery and
[ __ ] like that
but because they didn't find like they
didn't find any walls or anything so
they don't think that this was a
permanent Roman settlement they think
this was maybe a camp like a that was
kind of like constructed by people that
were like on their way to you know to
wherever it was they were going so you
know it's it's not like it was a
permanent settlement but they do think
that I mean I they're not really sure
what these dudes did if it was just like
some kind of they were criminals and
this was some kind of horrible
punishment but it's like you know
cutting the dude's legs off and then
cutting the other dude in half so they
made somebody mad clearly it sounds it
sounds like something an old Lee an
old-fashioned legal system did somebody
probably some kind of punishment for
cowardice or runnin punishment for
running away that's what they were
thinking because it was the leg so
basically almost all those damned
old-fashioned punishments usually
directed whatever did the wrong yeah it
always seemed like it was very on the
nose like you know whatever you did got
your feet right so you can't run anymore
yeah but yeah now apparently like it
like I said this article was from June
of 2018 and they said the teeth and the
bones are actually you know is [ __ ] up
and mutilated as they were actually in
really good condition so they should be
able to get like good carbon-14 dating
and [ __ ] like that where they can figure
out at least where these dudes came from
and like you know about what time period
that this was you know when they were
probably killed alright so now let's
talk a little bit about mm-hmm excuse me
the villa of the mysteries now this is
actually a suburban ancient Roman villa
it was a private residence
they're not really sure who owned it on
the outskirts of Pompeii now um
obviously it was buried by ash in the
eruption of Mount Vesuvius in 79 AD
however it is remarkably well preserved
and there's like a lot of really cool
like frescoes in there it's one of the
earliest examples earliest extant
examples of Roman painting although the
mystery is that they're not entirely
sure what it's like a series of freezes
that seems to show like a story but
they're not entirely sure what that
story is they have some ideas about what
it might be yeah there's a lot of Roman
stuffs like that like kind of like there
are Roman stories that are recorded that
we don't even understand we understand
what they symbolize yeah you know in in
their mythology because they're talking
about they're promoting values that we
don't have anymore yeah you know well
like I said a lot of and we talked about
this you know even [ __ ] that's like only
a hundred years old it's hard to figure
that it's hard to figure because the
context the social context has been
completely lost like you know you don't
you didn't live back then you don't know
you know it and even something like that
where we have like copious writings from
people of the period and like you know
we know what people were doing and
whatnot
you know even then we can't figure out
what exactly they were thinking or how
exactly should be working there was an
important Roman religious tale you know
there's some kind of it was a mythos
that promoted something I mean somebody
out there knows knows the names of the
gods the DEM ago some demigod runs down
and grab some mint for sprite or some
[ __ ] like that she's supposed to be real
for gentle and beautiful he grabs her
she can't she can't get away from him so
she turns into a damn tree and stays a
tree like you do like she does and
nobody knows what the [ __ ] that means
what better to [ __ ] it better together
be a tree there could be a treat and
give up a [ __ ]
I mean was that what does it mean dottie
raped better to die than be raped what
does it mean I think that probably is
yeah I mean that's your virtue at all
that's kind of like I feel like that's
probably because I
feel like there are more even more
modern like stories in that that have a
similar theme yeah and that does seem to
be a similar theme in a lot of those
types of stories where you know for a
woman like her virtue yeah it's like you
can't get soiled right or you know you
should die I can't get your status yeah
because you're damaged goods you're used
up well I guess what did what the deal
was just think they were think they were
trying to say that she was so pure that
she would rather die than to lose that
purity yeah like I said that seems like
that was a pretty common right uh thing
pretty Ilyn like I think I'm a lot of
that was like in medieval literature and
stuff like that I think there was a lot
of that kind of stuff going on in there
but um so so I imagine those probably
say but I mean could be totally wrong I
don't you know I don't know it's not I
said see the thing is that the stories
aren't really narrated and they're not
there's no commentary autumn in the
story yeah I'm supposed to understand
what it means that's what I mean oh so
it's like a lot of that's what I mean
about all the cultural context being
lost and even something as recent as a
hundred years ago 200 years ago when we
when he when we had rioting and [ __ ]
like that and we knew what all the words
meant it's like but since you didn't
live back then you didn't get like all
the weird like connotations that were
meant by certain things and you know
it's just it's a shame because we'll
never know I mean we can figure some of
it out you can piece some of it together
but I don't think you'll ever will ever
know completely I think if you were
living thousands years from now and all
you have is like a few seconds from Star
Wars you know I'm gonna have that damn
scene where Vader goes no I am you will
never know the [ __ ] context of them
or the meaning of that yeah that's
exactly and that's like 50 years from
now they'll probably be debating that
and they'll probably also be what does
that mean that's really funny to think
about now I want to invent a time
machine just the whole purpose of going
into the future and seeing if anyone's
debating about that yeah or they might
not even care because like I mean I
guess we're still talking about stuff
that happened like 2,000 years ago not
all the time but you know people are
still interested in it so I guess people
would still gonna look back on Disney
Star Wars and go
I don't think they're really I don't
think they're really like I said we're
we're not what we're not worried about
like what the what movies they were
watching - yes Mandalorian thing but I
don't want to pay for it they say it's
good series well yeah you can probably
see it something they're calling it baby
Yoda baby it's not Yoda though yeah you
know they just called the child it's a
different creature it's a different
person
well yeah because like I said he sees
yeah well that's good that they put
another one in there because like when
you think about the movies like when I
was thinking about when I saw Empire
Strikes Back as a kid and you'd be like
Yoda and you thought it was just Yoda
and that was it but then you had to
think oh well there's really a whole
races Yodas neo die whatever I don't
know no yeah no Yoda somebody knows what
it yeah what is what is big Yoda species
I don't know what are they called
I don't know it's out there somebody's
got well I could got that yes man
universe you know you could look it up
yeah like I said because you know
Chewbacca's a Wookiee well what's the
order then I don't know I don't know I'm
not I'm not that much of a geek but yeah
I'm just gonna looks like a gnome or
something you know it's cute yeah it's
like it's just funny how quickly that
baby Yoda thing like caught on in the
[ __ ] popular culture I see yeah I
need to see the Mandalorian and it's
like I just seen yeah it was like okay
you can't give a Star Wars toy around
but they didn't have that damn baby Yoda
everyone to buy it when that thing came
out of his behind that's it well yes you
could because it's cute as hell yeah
like I said I've never even seen the
show and I we might have one cause look
how adorable that [ __ ] is this is big
looks like a little bit yeah you guys
got that [ __ ] recorded know the address
what did it what's it even on what is it
on it's on Disney I'm not gonna pay for
this no it's under Disney streaming yeah
it's on a screen and I would watch all
that I would just [ __ ] watch that
[ __ ] [ __ ] all in like two or three
days well they probably they probably do
like um I mean shudder and Netflix and
everything like that well does like what
a seven day free they don't know the way
they won't [ __ ] they need to start
selling that [ __ ] a car yeah I can
subscribe just to a certain series
although like I said it's a lot better
than it used to be because remember back
in the day and like I said I you know I
knew this because my dad works for a
cable company for since the early 80s
and basically we used to [ __ ] because
you could only have so many packages
that was like you know the the lame
package the better package the one with
all the pay channels like all the movie
channels and it's like so you ended up
with like a hundred channels 500
channels whatever and it's like you
didn't really want Muslim and it was
just kind of like a pain in the ass step
to [ __ ] scroll through and like look
for the channel you we get we get cable
here almost for free along with our
internet connection and I [ __ ] I've
never really looked at cable it's only
when the damn Walking Dead we yeah we
watched Walking Dead about it but I
looked through the guide one time I was
just [ __ ] laughing how many channels
they are there are now on cable and how
many it's just [ __ ] well the thing is
that a lot of them it seemed it sounds
like infomercial channels yeah there's
that but it's like it seems like a lot
but a lot of them are kind of repeated
because one there'll be a channel and
then they'll be like an HD version of
that channel then there was a
pay-per-view section in there that had
porn yeah that looks interesting
oh yeah this is like you're paying for
porn come on it's the 21st century who
pays for porn
unless you have like really really
specific like [ __ ] that you like I don't
really know I pay for porn when you can
make your own all the technology
knowledge in the world go ahead all
right so we were talking what we were
talking about okay yeah the villa of the
mysteries so yeah so this villa is kind
of like set apart a little bit from I
think it's only like a quarter of a mile
away from like the main site of Pompeii
they've also found some nearby stables
and stuff like that that had like the
remains of horses and stuff in there
which is like [ __ ] kills oh he was
like two thousand year old horse
skeletons that's crazy
so that must that doesn't happen
I've worked round bars you know as if
it's my family's [ __ ] involved in the
horse business anyway
you don't bury a damn horse inside a
barn that's only well no they're not but
they were it was right now no it was
buried under the ash from the volcano
like oh hey where now pop it okay yeah
yeah yeah that's why I nobody buried
that me then but I didn't yeah just like
everything else was because like I said
I remember like all those horrifying I
remember when I was a kid my strange
stories amazing facts book that I kind
of that I've brought up a bunch of times
on this show and it had a sectional like
a little article and stuff like that
about Pompeii and it had like the
pictures of the people which is always
the first thing that like freaked me out
about because those that's like a real
person and they were gagging and died
and they were just like and that like
they had like horrible like you know the
the positions of their bodies and like
their [ __ ] mouths are open and you
could tell they were like freaking like
oh sure so my people were killed pretty
quickly by that I hope so [ __ ] man other
ones look like that they were gagging
and gagging and coughing yeah as the ash
was falling they were kind of twisted so
I think they were trying to keep above
the hash why they were gagged yeah can
you imagine God that must've been
horrible and then it retinol right next
to the person be a dog curled up and
[ __ ] it's pretty it's funny yeah there's
like a baby like in a cradle and stuff
ugh and then people people [ __ ] man
you guys haven't seen it man go check
this [ __ ] out it's sucking quite
shocking in a way it's very human yeah
well you can go see and I mean you can
go to Pompeii and like walk through
there and look at it as soon as you see
like the situation's of the Damned
plaster casts of the bodies you're you
can tell like little tableaus of what
happened yeah I know like people on a
corner all trying to [ __ ] protect one
another as they were dying there might a
little child in there or there might be
a dog next to the person you know two
minutes it's it's kind of touching you
know because even though that was you
know over 2,000 years ago there were
still people yeah those are still people
there's you know they were acting like
people and you can kind of see you can
kind of get a feel of like aw damn you
know I mean this one was trying to save
that one they were trying you know they
were trying to die together
you know don't ya I think that's what
they were trying to comfort each other
while they were dying you know you could
see that conscious that's what freaked
me out the most about like seeing like
all those bodies like in the pictures
and stuff like that is that you know I
think when you see you know other types
of things like mummies and stuff like
that that's fair I mean those are dead
people too but it's very stylized and
it's like you know that those people you
know were just that was prepared like
after death and everything like that so
it's like you don't get the sense of I
guess like immediacy that you get with
like the bodies at Pompeii because like
you said you can tell what these people
are we're doing exactly the moment that
they died and how horrifying it must
have been to just be like in your house
and all of a sudden look out the [ __ ]
window and the volcano is erupting and
then there's like [ __ ] just ash just
raining down on you and you can't go
anyplace yeah and then they were just
like weird [ __ ] like you'd find little
slave girls dead slave girls and [ __ ]
German German slave girls you know and
they would sometimes he you tell they
were kind of overworked other times
they'd have little jewelry on them which
we meant they were kind of favored you
know what I mean but whoever owned um
you know it's just it's just weird you
know so it's weird to be able to look
back in time like that yeah they give us
plenty of the elder or plenty of the
younger remember which one of us about I
think the elder died the younger
survived a--they they wrote about the
eruption yeah well he saw it didn't saw
it and they ran towards it yeah and he's
cool no master cuz all his slaves are
trying to stop him he was on a boat at
the time and now I might have this wrong
this is all you know my drunken memories
from memory my drunken memories but he
they were out there on vacation on the
damn yacht basically and he's ordering
his [ __ ] crude to go in there and he
had slaves with him gone no no don't go
you know don't go that kind of [ __ ]
because no we got to get closer they
were natural scientists this plant II
was yeah and you know he wrote books on
nature and science and they were he was
not religious he was an atheist a lot of
them were back yeah
that was you read writings and [ __ ] from
this era especially like Julius Caesar
when he's going to pacify in certain
provinces as the next military man I
read his writings in menace just sounds
like it was just written yesterday a lot
of the stuff that wrote is very modern I
found hey you know you're definitely
dealing with a guy with like 150 145 IQ
I mean these are not dummies
yeah and they sound very very modern
it's like something that was just
written yesterday and some of the
political commentary sounds like it was
written today yeah
but they had different standards he not
a man like [ __ ] Julius and be like
yes and we attacked the compound for a
good two and a half hours and then once
we broke through
I let the men go in and rape and pillage
for a little while so they could blow
off steam and then I called him back off
and we went back to fighting and then
you know I rewarded them later I let him
go rape him pill it's a little bit more
and then I called him to come back good
cop in rape yeah yeah go rape and
pillage myself it's kind of you know
they didn't they didn't play back there
I mean as smart as they were and as on
the ball as they were they still hadn't
gotten ahold of that whole women or
humans to think they didn't care didn't
care though in those days if you you
were not you know the Romans were right
and good non Romans were days basically
in barbarians and they needed to be
pacified neither both sides I think had
bad habits okay but they were a very
structured type it's a civilization
where might made right if you had a
badass you could do whatever you wanted
men were in charge and and alpha men
were in charge regular men and other men
were betas and he literally gave up the
booty sometimes to these dudes he
thought I mean it just that was the
thinking of the day was yes I just punch
or but [ __ ] you yeah it was almost
imagine like a maximum-security prison
open air prison that's kind of the way
that's actually a good comparison Wow
pretty much of it yeah and you're just
so man that
other men were women in comparison to
you you know I mean it's that kind of
[ __ ] you know
and I had to do with status and there
were different classes like equestrians
and patricians and if you were a
patrician male of high standard of high
income and high power you you ruled
everything underneath you you know so it
was super super it was a super
hierarchical you yeah and that's just
the way it was yeah and that was the
natural order to thing this whole this
whole thing about equality man that's
all [ __ ] back in ancient Rome that
was not something that was real
everything was about that well I don't
even think it was something that
occurred to them right now I even think
about it that was that would have been
something totally unnatural to them I
mean I do think that it occurred to a
few awesome people full offers it did
occur to them because I have read
ancient Greek and Roman writers that
sounded very like a very enlightenment
era philosopher so it did occur to some
people but I don't think they had enough
say or power to they were a the Romans
were a macho [ __ ] people and quite
stylish
they were quite a stylist I didn't like
body hair you know the man they liked to
be very fit they were manscaped they
were manscaped they worked out they
understood they understood strength and
beauty they were big into that they
worked out they went to this damn bath
houses and baths and open-air baths they
were basically nudists yeah
men women children all mixed in together
basically thank you check out my good
stuff yeah actually I think the men and
the women on certain worse actually
separated in the bit I think it may be
dependent I mean the Roman Empire was
pretty big so I'm not really sure it
might have been different in different
look yeah and also things changed over
time yeah you know and also there's a
lot of private stuff going on and then
it's like they even they even had the
whole Epstein Island thing down the
island of Capri was basically the Roman
version of FC's Island yeah they had all
that near Earth where you could go if
you wanted to see a dojo or it was it
near excuse me that was uncle Tiberius
as [ __ ]
Island that's what Caligula [ __ ]
that's right Caligula was ridiculous he
yeah that we show about that
that island [ __ ] a little Caligula and
when he came out he [ __ ] hated
humanity you know he took it out on the
Romans and it just tells you it just
goes to show you that you're ruling
class is not who you think they are
absolute power corrupts absolutely
and if you that don't believe that will
always be true just some breed where
ancient Roman history and understand
that that's happening in most countries
yeah the ruling classes are like that
the sad thing is is probably a little
bit better than it was back then but
yeah you know say it's still the same
[ __ ] though well I think what what made
it better back then is that they were
open about it they didn't hide it they
weren't deceitful about it well because
what would anyone have done yeah they
knew what was going on on the on the
island of Capri and everyone's like men
yeah problem technically it wasn't
illegal well yeah that's what I mean
it's like probably people wouldn't have
even been bothered it was just kind of
it was just kind of like back in the old
days when you know a 20 year old man
could marry like an 11 year old girl and
no one batted an eye cuz that was just
what happened hey she's had her period
she needs to start having kids grandma
she's ready to go she ready to go that's
you know well nowadays people be
horrified but it's like and rightly so
but back then on Capri it was open that
there were little children men the
little girls and little boys running
around dressed his nips and pans or
nymphs and satyrs and their running
around in the wilderness they were their
little slave children you know sex slave
children misses the emperor yep and it
was legal yeah [ __ ] they're rare that's
wild that's what I mean and if he got
any if he made it he made uncle Tiberius
man you throw you off the damn cliff yep
yeah like I said we'll kind of get into
that a little bit when we talk about
look us to the poisoner but it's like
it's kind of like it was almost just
kind of like knocking off your relatives
like to get to the throat or whatever
was totally not I'm not saying
that it was legal necessarily but it was
just part of tradition it was just kind
of something that you did yeah and like
everyone like you know somebody died
it's like what I don't know it was maybe
they just were sick or whatever and
everyone is just like okay you have to
understand this all of us alive right
now in the United States we grew up and
were raised in an environment of law and
order where there was a legal system
that we could kind of trust to make sure
justice happened in theory yeah okay if
you're rich enough here it looks like
you can avoid that yeah yeah obviously
now you have to remember that law
enforcement and this legal system that
we have now is actually not that old no
it's not the United States didn't have
police really until not modern police
until they would in mid-20s something
like yeah I mean early 21 before then
there were no cops no [ __ ] figure I
mean not like cops nowadays no no a cop
back then was basically just like a
security guard and everybody carried
guns yeah everybody did you you know cuz
there weren't any cops every every man
was a cop and every woman was a cop two
women carried little purse pistols and
it was like a like a beat colony or an
ant colony you know bee colony everybody
carries stinger and now the violence was
pretty bad yeah but I don't think it was
as bad as the 70s though 60s and 70s is
pretty I guess it's kind of hard to
compare because the records are I mean
the 70s they obviously have really good
records but in that situation the
culture of the time yeah it was just
kind of like a different thing so
because we're so-called civilized people
that grow up with cops and and and
expectation and expectations we it's
hard for us to kind of put ourselves the
way it was back then but it's weird we
have to it's weird when you think about
it that you know only a few generations
back there weren't any police yeah you
just kind of had to cover you humans did
don't actually need police most
civilizations never had them you can go
back to the ancient Assyrians and the
[ __ ] Persians you have cops yeah it
was just a higher
the hierarchies what kept the order and
that's what this is all about well you
did something bad they'd cut you in half
juice yeah somebody higher rank than you
would go imma imma kill you and they
would do it oh yeah no one would really
do anything yeah I mean you know oh yeah
so all right so Villa de mysteries like
I said was this one particular house
private residence it's not that far from
Pompeii and as I said it is remarkably
well-preserved it wasn't actually like
you know when the volcano erupted it
didn't like [ __ ] up the walls or
anything like that it was buried under
the ash but it like preserved it so
pretty much the walls and ceiling and
stuff like that are intact
and you can actually see there's some
cool on YouTube there's some cool like
3d like videos like they go all around
the villa and like you can see like what
it looks like and all the paintings look
remarkably well-preserved like a couple
of them have some like chunks of plaster
that fell out and stuff like that but
all the paint looks like really vibrant
and stuff so the villa itself is
actually named the villa of the
mysteries because of these particular
paintings which are actually only in one
room of the residence now they think
they're this room might have either been
a dining room like a dining room type
thing like which they would have called
it I tried triclinium or it might have
been like a small bedroom of the woman
of the house which would be called a
cubiculum they're not really sure which
of the two that it was so these frescoes
that are on the walls they think they
come from the early or middle first
century now they're not entirely sure
what is happening in these frescoes
however the most common interpretation
is that this is depicting a woman who
was going through an initiation into a
cult of Bacchus right this this was like
a that was the Bacchus was a cult all
about booze getting drunk it's the
getting drunk also getting drunk oh we
need to start one of those it makes
sense when in English you know the word
spirits
manok usually goes to describe hard
liquor and spirits because they'd really
know how liquor worked I don't think you
drink something and all of a sudden you
start acting funny feeling fine must be
the spirits
it's like spirit so yes so like way back
in a day especially during the Roman
time so they had wine didn't have
distilled alcohol but they had wine and
they would get drunk and they couldn't
they couldn't explain why so they
thought a spirit was coming going
through them and you know anything that
spiritual is good you know and if you
feel good then it's good so they had God
that they called Bacchus who was in who
was the that was the spirit that flowed
through you when you were drinking all
that one party God it was the party yeah
you know religions I think I think a lot
of religions started that way you know
hallucinations and hail and [ __ ]
because the Oracles were inhaling
[ __ ] gases it would make them [ __ ]
speak gibberish and [ __ ] getting high
was a serious you know it's like I'm one
of the main parts of uh of religions you
know like for instance I'm I'm gonna go
out on a limb alright Moses saw God in a
burning bush
alright what bush was this how close was
he standing to it he's not breathing
that smoke okay yeah alright there's a
lot of little you know and then like you
know in Revelations somebody [ __ ]
takes a little book in his hand and eats
it and all of a sudden sees God what's
on this book a little piece of paper
it's like early oh yeah come on about so
you know there's no Talon you know
because I suspect that you're probably
right about that because like I said if
you just go around like eating plants
and various things and I'm not having
and not knowing that it's the plant
that's causing that or even if you do
know I mean if they didn't have any
understanding of like you know what the
hell understanding of a cellular right
cells metabolism right chemicals none of
that was known all they knew is that you
ate something and all of a sudden a
spirit went through you and you started
out you started [ __ ] acting funny
started seeing things and understanding
things and going wow then you're coming
up with stuff you know and then you're
having new ideas and you're tripping the
[ __ ] out you might so in the mind of
these people this is God yeah or a
god-like being that's doing this well
yeah because it's so out of your normal
right day-to-day life yeah and they
don't know what your consciousness is or
kind of the alt you know or what an
altered consciousness is or chemicals or
anything so they they're gonna come up
with a damn religious explanation of why
they got drunk why they got high it
seems like a good cover story man it's
like you know what I mean
yeah and you had and they had fun so
therefore was good yeah well much more
fun than like the later like the
Victorians and stuff like that it's like
oh it's it's fun you need to stop doing
it although they were doing they were
doing it - yeah
well yeah before that well it was all in
opium and all that kind of [ __ ] was
legal and also the precursors of [ __ ]
ecstasy
yeah available during that time they
were messing with that - yeah so yeah so
I do definitely feel like you're
probably right about that about all the
different plants and booze and stuff
like that yeah seeing God in a burning
bush and the burner bush that's me
because seriously like you said if you
read the book of Revelation how high was
that David there weren't that yeah yeah
and getting getting to Genesis you know
with the burning bush I'm never gonna
say that Moses saw a burning bush
alright it's just as somebody inserted a
burning bush into the story of Moses
because they were [ __ ] with they saw
a God - Sarah yeah because Moses was not
a historical figure just no way no way
yeah I've already been through all this
yeah
and that's a that's mythological
character well they have counterparts in
earlier yeah
pagan belief systems yes Jesus does
Moses does like all of the main biblical
characters Jesus is a reboot of Moses in
many ways yeah yes oh yeah well a lot of
like the Old Testament stories are kind
of like repeated like rebooted in the
New Testament as well and the ones in
the Old Testament are kind of reboots of
older and most various pagans Moses
Moses is a reboot of Sargon yeah it's
all gone oh my god
yeah um so yeah so this woman in this in
this series of paintings they think that
that she's going through this initiation
to become a member of this cult of
Bacchus mainly because there are some
other like figures in the paintings that
they think are mean ads which are female
followers of Bacchus because they've
seen them like an other artwork before
so these mean ads are usually shown as
like they have like really swirly like
drapery and stuff and they're usually
seen like dancing and they have been
seen on like Greek pottery and stuff
like that and this was like even before
this particular cult had spread to this
part of the world now there are its
other differing interpretations like
some people think it's a girl getting
married and stuff like that but it does
seem that with these particular other
figures in there that look like they're
dancing and stuff this does seem like
it's kind of showing an initiation right
I believe it's seven phrases or seven
panels so in the first panel there is
what appears to be a Roman noblewoman
and it looks like she's walking up to a
priestess or something like that who's
sitting on a throne and then there's
like a little boy reading a scroll which
you know if the being initiated into the
cult of Bacchus thing is correct then
this is the boy like announcing the
initiation or making a declaration of it
or whatever now on the other side of the
throne there's another woman who was
presumably the initiating like this
purple robe and a crown made out of
Myrtle and she has a sprig of Laurel and
a tray of cakes which it seems like she
is
you know that that may be some kind of
offering to like whoever it is that
she's initiating into so then there's
like the second mural which has this
other woman who is presumably another
priestess or somebody like that and she
has like some assistance or something
with her and they're preparing what is
called they lick I guess it's called a
lick non basket or something like that I
guess it's like non basket which is just
like a basket that they put like
offerings in just like figs or something
like that
and then on one side there's like this
horsey looking guy and he's playing a
liar
they're presuming that this is a
representation of salinas who was the
companion of beckus who was kind of
horsey looking so that's another point
in the Bacchus things favor
the third mural shows that there's like
a satyr and he's playing panpipes and
then there is a nymph suckling a goat so
nice yeah like they like they do now the
initiate is in this one but she seems
like she's freaking out for some reason
and then like she's not in the next few
you know murals so they're assuming that
maybe at this point she's kind of like
gone into what they call cata bosses I
think that's how you pronounce it her
kada bosses which is literally like a
descent into the underworld and that
maybe she's like Wiggin out cuz she's
going into the underworld man like later
she'll be back and she'll be changed cuz
she's not in like the next couple of
phrases right so cuz she's kind of like
looking and she looks like super
horrified and like freaking out and
everything so then the next one which is
the fourth mural that one shows like a
satyr and then the horsey guy is like
giving him a bowl of wine and then
there's another satyr and he has like
this really scary mask and then the
satyr that's drinking the wine like sees
the mask reflected in the bowl which
they think might be a reference to the
mirror that Bacchus stares into like
it's that Orphic rights thing and then
there's another there's a goddess in
this one who they think might be Ariadne
or perhaps sommelier I guess is how you
pronounce that and the Hat and Bacchus
is lying across her lap
now the fifth one the initiate returns
but she looks different like now she has
a staff and she has a cap on so
presumably her initiation has been
completed at this point she's like
kneeling before this figure who was
apparently the priestess and there's
also like a female figure with wings
that looks like it's whipping her which
you know nice then there's like a
dancing figure next to her which they
think is a mean ad which is you know a
follower Bacchus and this other female
figure with a gown on that is carrying
what they call a thirst which is I guess
is an initiation symbol of Bacchus and
it's like this
they're like made of like fennel like
these long strips stalks of fennel and
then this like has a pine cone on top so
I guess that was something that they
gave them and then the sixth one which
is the second-to-last
she has they're putting new clothes on
her like this is her new identity or
whatever and then there's Cupid and he's
holding up a mirror like hey see how
awesome you look now that you're
initiated into the cult of Bacchus or
whatever and then there's another image
of Cupid also and then in the last mural
they showed the initiate the same woman
she's like on a throne and she has like
this really elaborate costume on so
that's why I mean to me that seems more
like I know like other archeology said
like it could be a wedding ceremony but
it does seem to me that this is more
like initiation into a cult type of
thing I mean when you see the murals and
you hear the way they're described and
like you know what each figure probably
represents I think that's probably what
it is depicting yeah that's what they're
talking which is interesting because it
could be that the person that lived in
this house because like I said they
don't know who lives in this house who
lived in this house may have been an
initiate into this cult you know what I
mean and this would they were showing
like their symbolic like initiation into
it this is a typical Roman cult yeah
there were lots of these there you know
actually okay what's who way to put this
I don't want to offend anybody Rome was
very famous for having fake religion
and fake foreign religions yeah you
could go through there and say they have
a good at it they had a cult of Isis
which is an Egyptian fake religion they
had what was his name damn what was the
name of that damn cult it was a Persian
cult which one Mithras Mithras yeah yeah
they had a cult of Mithras which was the
Roman version of Mithra ISM yeah okay
and then they had a fake version of
Judaism in Rome you know it as
Christianity yeah not to make anybody
mad well that's how it started out it's
out started out and how this would go
down is there were there was a lot of
immigration into Rome people from all
over the world would go to Rome and they
would bring their religions with him and
they would end up in these damn
neighborhoods all living in there
together but as time would go on over
the generations these new Romans or and
and I don't I don't think they were all
citizens either because how to become a
citizen in Rome was very different but
they were Roman sub subjects would be a
good way to put it they realized that
their religions weren't quite as cool as
the other religions around them so they
would romanize him yeah all right they
would turn him into something that was
that would fit in better now Rome had a
big religious industry and these foreign
religions had to adapt and to the market
and be able to compete in this market so
they all became romanized the Egyptian
ones did the Persian ones did and the
Judyann ones did you know which created
Christianity and usually what what a
cult was is it was a small religion
under the imperial cult of Rome rich
people all worshipped the Imperial cult
poor people had their own ethnic
usually how this went down as you went
to a place they called it a temple but
you went to this place and you would
have like a multimedia experience okay
there would be a live stage show yeah
maybe you would drink alcohol maybe you
would drink some kind of weird drugs and
you'd watch this live reenactment of
something some kind of initiation right
you know like if it was a Mithra ism it
was some kind of a Mithras coming out of
a rock and then transforming and a Last
Supper and then him sacrificing a bull
and then him being somehow cheating
death but we don't know the story
because we only have the we only have
the fresco so we don't have the barely
sure like what yes exactly
later on Christian's destroyed all his
books so you know we don't know and you
know this is the same kind of deal there
was some kind of story that went along
with those frescoes yeah well guess what
Christianity was also one of those yeah
they actually would reenact you know
probably you know depending on what year
we're talking about they would probably
in reenact the crucifixion and somehow
Jesus ascending to heaven or surviving
in heaven because you know I'm gonna
refer you back to dr. Robert and price
he's been a [ __ ] guest on the show
this guy really knows his [ __ ]
Christianity evolved a lot over the
years if you look at the oldest writing
Christian writings it is not the Gospels
it's in fact the Pauline epistles and
the Pauline epistles don't mention
anything that happened in in the Gospels
no earthly Jesus no earthly you know no
miracles or anything it's just a Jesus
in heaven
yeah largely spiritual thing yeah it
seems to be one of the sons of God that
they're talked about in
in the Old Testament like in Genesis
sons of God or course are the Angels and
it's it's an angel above Michael that
you can pray to to be saved from God's
law so that way you're not being judged
by the law you're actually being saved
by grace because Jewish law was too hard
you couldn't get around it you were
going to hell god damn can't do all this
[ __ ] come on it would be equivalent to
say being here in the United States a
whole bunch of people from the Middle
East moving in here that believe in
Islam and over a few generations Islam
isn't really fitting into well so they
make Islam a more American you know I
mean they make it more like Christianity
well that's what the ancient Romans were
doing they were moving into Rome from
places like Egypt and places like Persia
and places like Judea and making their
religions more Roman yeah all right well
if you were from Judea and the Jews at
that time are not the modern Jews you
would know today you know they're not
acidic Jews you know this is a long time
before that the Jews we're talking about
in this era actually worship an entire
pantheon of gods
kind of like the ancient Greeks and the
ancient Romans themselves so they go
into Rome and they change their Old
Testament base to gods to make it more
Roman well damn man when you really kind
of look at the literature and everything
if you were to romanize ancient Judean
or ancient Jewish religions it would
look like Christianity it's a perfect
that's a perfect [ __ ] Roman knockoff
yeah of Judaism and that's what
Christianity is it is not Middle Eastern
it's not even it's a Roman copy of a
Middle Eastern religion or is it just
has that kind of veneer over because
like I yeah I feel like that's something
that happened
everywhere just very organically yes
people move into a new area it's like
they're gonna pick up over a few
generations yeah they're gonna pick up
influences from their new you know
culture like you know other people that
they meet that are different from them
so it's like you know you're just gonna
like it's gonna all become like kind of
intertwined together
yeah and that's like a very organic
process yeah and if if Judaism goes into
Rome and becomes romanized the only way
it's gonna survive is to adopt the Roman
cult model that's the way the other
religions survive unless you go to a
temple you [ __ ] pay for an experience
and you watch a [ __ ] the theater act
you know what I mean and hears songs and
sing songs that's what happened that's
what that that's what happened to
Judaism and that's where Christianity
came from all right and that's that's
what they're talking about in this
religion that's what they were talking
about in Mithra ISM yeah today we would
know it as the as the club experience
you go to a club I was gonna say it's
almost kind of like they Roscoe it's
like it was just little fan clubs yeah
it's kind of going to like a nightclub
and your singing and your dancing and
you're taking or drinking something that
gives you a spiritual experience and
you're watching a live performance and
then you know and that's where the cult
of Bacchus was is all about how much
could you drink drink remain standing
and singing you know and they were
playing quarters it was yeah well we
think of we think of churches today is
something very pious for old people
really boring it's real serious and [ __ ]
but Rome was off the chain they didn't
play that you know you know there were
so many cults and so many temples
throughout the campus they had to be fun
so everybody and it was all about money
and all the technology was going there
yeah like all the Brahms best mechanical
technology went to these clubs the cults
yeah but it was a club experience yeah
there's like a nightclub and you know
which that's completely understandable
yeah like you said that did that was
kind of lit yeah that was
like your main entertainment option it
was the night club it was the movies it
was drug experience everything
it was dating it was everything all a
month and some of those cults of course
involves sex yeah so you know I'm not in
the ones we talked about but there were
other ones that involved [ __ ] roar
jeez yeah well what you're talking about
his clubs
yeah nightclubs yeah I don't think
that's the analogy yeah it was the
nightclub but with a spiritual element
to it so you could feel good about going
yeah yeah that going and guess what up
and getting in an orgy everybody who's
in the know understands that most of
these cults ran which would call kind of
like holy prostitution yeah where there
were prostitutes that raised money for
the cult
you know like Scientology not a big
difference but it hasn't changed at all
because like I said you know humans are
you know we're very diverse and stuff
like that but that we have parameters I
mean there's only so many different
right results you're gonna get yeah and
I'm not pre-action
and you know it's real popular today the
bag on Christianity you know I mean but
you know I don't bag on it I come from a
kind of Christian background but I
understand what it is and where it comes
from it's it's better to believe in
something than to believe in nothing and
these were old ways and it was all about
memes you know basically there's all
these little memes to give you values
and you know I mean to give you cultural
values you know well it seemed like the
quickest way to impart that yeah you're
doing people that half of them couldn't
read yeah so yeah so it seemed like kind
of a shorthand way of like hey we're
just all gonna do this you tell them
stories and through those stories they
learn values yeah you know like Star
Wars same [ __ ]
it always comes back to oh my god why
did the camera go so blurry right then I
don't know
okay you're wait you're moving around
too much right same thing yeah that's
why Hollywood tries to do what it does
it tries to promote values through
through words
whether they're accepted or not you know
a lot of [ __ ] the Hollywood [ __ ] mix
today I think it's [ __ ] crap but
there is there's good stuff coming out
of there too but you're talking about
ancient cults were the clubs and the
theaters of the day yeah oh definitely
yeah all right so we've gone a little
bit past the hour mark so I guess we're
gonna take a break right now when we
come back we're gonna talk about the
really fun [ __ ] mass graves and also low
cost of the poisoner okay I could die to
talk about her she's like super scary
but also also super kind of fun all
right yeah he's gonna go make another
drink so we were gonna take a break and
we will be back in just a few minutes
hmm what you doing sweetheart
yeah always robbing you robbing up on
Mama's desk I know you like to play
around with a little butt wagon
you're the most hilarious but and all
cat dog yes you do yes you do it's
always wiggling that's what I call their
wiggle like hey yeah I know it feels
good off there's no cute pokey no I
freaked her out
eat this
Oh what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing okay you just chill
okay bugle girl you be a good girl
you just hang out with mom and dad oh
you love true-crime
I love true-crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
from an incident the faithless villain
vol 3 is an involving exploration of
unsolved slang spanning the years from
1980 to 1999 pick up your copy and print
or eBook formats on Amazon or download
the audiobook version from audible.com
and get ready for a chilling journey
through modern crime history
all right we're back
hopefully oh I think little baby cookie
moved from underneath she was sitting
underneath the tripod of the camera so
it was kind of sad she's like she was I
said she's sitting in the middle like in
the cone of power she's like some
new-age kind of [ __ ] what she was trying
to get like she's rolling around energy
from the guy put my shoe down there
because she usually bites on the shoe
and she was like [ __ ] Ted shoes she
looked at me mad dude just like she was
like I'm not in the mood for that show
you now I just don't like it
but she loved shoes and she loves feet
yeah she was like I'm not in that movie
that shoe I'm not gonna move at you cuz
normally she will come after the shoes
and she really she's all into and she's
like very expressive she learned about
facial expressions from us I know she
does well we liked it and I don't think
we've said this on the show before but
the first day that we got I think it was
the first night that we got her like
that big she was tiny she was only well
um her eyes were still blue so she was
less than six weeks old when we got her
by just somebody that found her in their
yard presumably and so she was a little
skittish at first because you know we
have Beijing and she was a big cat and
everything but it's like we we took her
in the bedroom and we put her on the bed
and she was like sitting on the foot of
the bed and we were like sitting on at
the head of the bed and she like made
eye contact she looked like right she
looked at him then she looked at me yeah
then we looked and then I looked and she
looked at it and she was like what what
what what what yeah yeah it was the
weirdest thing I've never seen it can't
do that yeah she was very like even from
the beginning she was very very small
and from from the very beginning she was
very kind of like are you mommy and
daddy yeah yeah and then she was after
that she was like totally fine she was
like oh I guess my mommy and daddy she
just came and slept in the bed the first
night that we had her yeah carefully you
wouldn't roll over on her because she
was very little constantly her inin but
from then on after she mimicked
everything that we did in terms of
facial expressions and everything it's
like it's like a little human child she
is like a human child yeah and she
sleeps on her back she does things that
humans do yeah she still sleeps in the
bed yeah most of the time at least part
of the night
it's the weirdest thing I've never seen
you can't like that never I haven't
either she has like and I'm sure other
people will have cats like that but it's
like I've never had one very little cat
like quality to her more a lot more like
a monkey or a human yeah
she's very much like she does and she
has a little voice like she has little
rocks and little reflections and stuff
and you know [ __ ] like that but yeah so
anyway she left the room I don't know
where she went she was she was mad at us
some reason probably cuz I was recording
her and she don't like it she doesn't
like to be recorded so okay so now that
we're talking some more about some
weirdness in ancient Roman let's talk
about something really cheerful mass
infant graves how about this this is
pretty weird yeah this is some weird
[ __ ] right here so there's more than one
so we're gonna talk about like two
different sites so the first thing I'm
gonna talk about is actually it's a
seaport called Ashkelon I guess I'm
pronouncing that right it's in Israel on
the Mediterranean coast now a find was
made here by an archaeologist with the
somewhat unfortunate name of Ross Voss
we'll get into another archaeologist
with an even even more unfortunate name
later on we're talking about the other
site but Ross boss was exploring one of
the ancient sewers in this city because
archaeology is a really glamorous
profession yeah so while he was looking
through the sewer he finds a number of
small bones
at first he believes that these are
chicken bones and these are presumably
the ruins of you know ancient dinners or
whatever however it was later discovered
that the bones were actually human and
were actually infant bones from the
ancient Roman era it ended up that this
was the remains of more than 100 babies
so this particular this is not the only
one that's been found and like I said
I'll go into another one later on but
this is actually the largest discovery
of of infant remains from this time
period that has been found to date so
since he couldn't figure out like why
all these baby skeletons
in one place and how they might have
died so he takes them to a forensic
anthropologist
now the forensic anthropologist whose
name is Patricia and Smith notes that
there was didn't seem to be anything
wrong with any of these babies there
were no signs of illness no signs of
disease they all appeared to have been
perfectly healthy at the time of their
death and they had all died before they
were a week old so it's a mom pretty
much the new board's new ones now it
should be noted that during Roman times
it was not all that unusual for infants
to be killed as a form of crude birth
control yeah what they would usually do
is if a woman would have a baby and she
felt like she didn't really want it then
they would do what they called exposure
where they would just kind of leave at
some place you know and sometimes
someone would find it and you know adopt
it and take care of it but other times
it would just lay out until it died so
this it sounds terrible but this was
actually not illegal at the time because
it was believed widely that humans were
infants were not really human until they
were about six months old because they
didn't have a soul until then or
something like Davis yeah they just
weren't like developed and they did they
thought back then that they didn't feel
anything like they didn't feel any pain
or any emotion or well then they
probably figured they were animal like
it couldn't joke so that's probably what
it was yeah and that they wouldn't
remember anything so it's not like
you're dealing with a person that's yes
so that's what they're saying so they
thought you weren't thinking in
potentiality yeah they were thinking and
it was at that time yeah they were just
thinking it was like a little blob and
it was like kind of alive but it didn't
really have a soul it wasn't a please
just a very very late term abortion
that's yeah that's essentially what this
was so so it wasn't actually illegal to
just kind of like I don't want this kid
and you just kind of like leave it out
in your yard or whatever so yeah and in
fact as most people will know the very
famous story of the founding of room the
twins Romulus and Remus were actually
abandoned at birth
and we're raised by a she-wolf and then
went on to found room when they got
older whether that's true or not I know
it's not true but that is like you know
it's really the legend about pretty much
everyone knows that's mythology yeah
yeah you know whether those two guys
were real guys or not I'm not really
sure but the whole thing about them
being raised by a wolf and stuff like
that nobody thinks that's the case I
don't remember all the details but I saw
the thing where someone explained what
the symbology of the story meant yeah
there was a symbolism to it that
ancients understood a lot better than we
did abandoned children being suckled by
a wolf I think one had to kill the other
didn't it I can't even remember how
that's like that but there was there's a
next there's a there's a symbolic
explanation for everything in that story
so it couldn't have been good yeah it's
like I said I you know yeah there have
been cases you know in history of kids
raised by animals but a lot of them are
not now from what I remember the intent
of the story meant that the Romans were
basically a people that were about
fighting to the death for survival that
that's what yes which may well there
were wolf-like predators type people
yeah you know and if you know about the
history of Roman that's what you're
talking about
yeah it's where they were I mean I can
see how you would want like the founders
of your city to be like these badass so
they were babies and it's like they were
left but then this wolf came so they
were almost like halfling werewolves
right you know what I mean do the same
thing today though Eagles yeah true
Eagles are things that [ __ ] lords of
the sky big regal Birds swooped down and
just [ __ ] your ass up and then after
they're done you just sit up there
looking pretty you know that's an eagle
you know it's funny because I had seen
Eagles like bald eagles and stuff like
flying in the sky every now and then but
it's like you know you never get a sense
of how big they are huge until you see
them because I saw one like when I was a
teenager like I saw one you know sitting
there and I was like holy [ __ ] that
thing's [ __ ] enormous when I was at
the barn man I saw one of them come down
out of the sky didn't actually seen but
I heard of hit boom and I turned and
looked
and he [ __ ] douve on a pile of
horseshit something any [ __ ] looking for
some but it wasn't there any left he's
like a damn [ __ ] car impact they're
very very very large yeah [ __ ] with same
thing happened with like pelicans like
I'd always seemed like I grew up in
Daytona Beach you know I grew up like
we're in the Atlantic Ocean so I saw
pelicans like flying all the time
but one time I was fishing with my
family to Pelican landed only like three
feet away from me and I'm like holy [ __ ]
they're good they were a big it's me
yeah I can believe how [ __ ] big they
were and it's you know growing bald
eagle man about three feet tall there
looks like the [ __ ] size of a [ __ ]
like the size of a [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ]
he's pretty big well it's not something
you'd run up on no definitely not your
heart anyway yeah the top that talons
looked huge and he was just like in
tearing through that horseshit looking
for whatever it was I don't think I
don't think there was anything in there
yeah I think he I think his experience
told him that that sometimes sometimes
the rice and rats there was things in
there
right yeah he don't like oh that's a big
pile of [ __ ] sometimes you just have
prizes inside yeah it was horseshit I
guess not nowadays I'm not like I guess
I'm not as impressed by how big the
birds are because we have sandhill
cranes everywhere and those [ __ ]
things are gigantic dinosaur birds you
know they try to get in the back door
they try to get in the back door yeah
they'll knock did not to come in I fed
him I made a mistake
well that's why they tell you not to do
that yeah because they just keep coming
for that exact reason it all somehow
they're super loud yeah and they're very
intelligent somehow they spread the word
because it was more than one family that
came asking for food that's what birds
are not dumb man yeah they're pretty
smart you feed that's why they tell you
not to feed them around here because you
feed one it's like it goes and tells its
friends with that really loud annoying
call it I took some video of that [ __ ]
did you ever post it on the show I don't
think it was in the show I don't even
remember what happened in that video cuz
that was a while I think I probably
still have it to say no cranes big man
almost four feet tall they
they're about four people I feed them by
hand certain select families yeah cuz
it's always like a little family it's
like a little mom and a dad and they
think God what do you do they've got a
baby I might feed him a little bit
you're not supposed to but they
specifically tell you not to but like I
said that's why because they because
they can fly I mean that they're almost
as big I mean they're big like an
ostrich but you know not quite as big as
that but they can fly and they make a
really really really really really loud
noise and also if you feed them once
they will never forget your ass and then
they'll knock on the bed and they will
come to your house and like knock on
your doors and windows and stuff like
that like time you fed us we're back
again like hey remember us yeah give me
some more that bran or granola or
whatever fetus yeah like that's probably
what started those damn stories of that
[ __ ] monster was the name of that
monster that flew out of the [ __ ] sky
Oh which one the one that they said that
they saw a standing on the side of the
road man or Mothman the Jersey Devil or
man in Jersey death I think Mothman as I
was think about I both suspect Mothman
might have been bought you know it's an
owl and stuff I'm like maybe it was a
crane because those [ __ ] are Mothman
is for Matt Mauck man was probably a
[ __ ] create a [ __ ] sandhill crane
cuz they're very big and they can't fly
when you see one of them and you deal
with one you can understand how that
might become Mothman they are pretty
intelligent and they'll eat right out of
your hand
yeah well the ones right here well and
make eye contact with you and they do
they do smart [ __ ] yeah yeah it's just
funny we see him right they are man like
yeah and like I said they're almost as
tall as I am like you know I mean
they're just they're about four feet
tall
okay so as I was saying now they had
found like graves of infants and stuff
before but you know obviously the
infants in these other grave sites were
more obviously we're it was like a
cemetery there's a wider range of Ages
it's like it looked like they had died
of various diseases and stuff
interestingly though it did not seem
that any of the babies at this
particular site in Ashkelon had died of
exposure
it appeared that all of them had been
intentionally murdered
um so what they were thinking
because the sewer where all of these
babies were found was beneath what they
believed was an ancient bathhouse that
perhaps these were babies that were born
to save prostitutes or people who worked
at the bathhouse and were abandoned you
know so the prostitutes could get back
to prostituting or whatever it was they
were doing yeah maybe but you know there
there are some arguments against that
too but if you buy more like the fact
that the women in that area knew that if
she went to the bathhouse you could have
a baby down there and throw it down on
the damn [ __ ] sewer
yeah maybe is that [ __ ] up though it's
like big that's the place where you go
the baby dumping area that baby dumping
area it's probably an empire and it
wasn't illegal no it wasn't because like
I said they didn't think that a baby was
a person until it was about six months
old infanticide was common and [ __ ]
pretty much all cold it was very common
who you know I think I told this before
was in Korea the things that [ __ ]
KATUSA KATUSA soldiers believed about
[ __ ] baby ghosts yeah and the
Japanese thought the same thing because
they were doing that yeah they were
killing babies after birth and of course
you know there's a certain amount of
guilt with that deep down they know that
they said that's bad so they were always
paranoid that the ghosts of those
children would [ __ ] come back and
haunt which makes total sense yeah I
mean the thing is I think that a lot of
times they didn't do it out of a sense
of like just being evil [ __ ]
they did it a Trachta Calladine race
because it's like one if you if you
rapport you didn't know about birth
control I mean I they did have birth
control methods but it's like you know
they're not a hundred percent effective
even nowadays so it's like if you
already had [ __ ] ten children and
then you got pregnant again and then
it's like what the [ __ ] am I gonna do
and you know the if they had taken like
some kind of you know drinking
pennyroyal tea or whatever we try to
have an abortion it's like if that
didn't work then you would just have to
dump it so you can't get too sentimental
about this you know I mean use it by
today's standards yeah what about
something that's
a country that is a third world country
by today's standards you know yeah that
had limited resources and vert and
limited technology women we get pregnant
and they just couldn't take care of
those babies yeah I mean once you had
and these women money and these women
didn't live long anyway true yeah I mean
[ __ ] I think that life expectancy was 30
yeah now you're talking about teenage
women a lot of them probably yeah and
people women in their 20s that maybe
already had kids that they had to feed
life the value of life back then was not
what it is today
yeah they just didn't think that way it
was very practical and they lived fast
and he died the day died yeah yeah well
I kind of feel like that's probably what
was going on yeah and they were doing
this in a basically a [ __ ] third
world country and I'm not saying that
they didn't feel bad about it like I
said I mean and obviously you know
particularly in you know cultures where
they have [ __ ] about baby goats and
stuff like that like in Korea and Japan
and stuff like that I mean the fact that
they even had you know you're right yeah
the fact that they even had myths like
that shows that they felt bad yeah they
were just doing it for practical reasons
it's like look we can't feed another one
they could then there's nothing else for
them to do they didn't have a choice
that's what I mean it's like they were
kind of like you know they were kind of
like in the corner yeah and they weren't
alone a lot of people were doing that at
that time yeah it was just something
that they all had to do and you have to
look at it in the context of the time
these people didn't live long yeah yeah
no yeah yeah yeah I'd you blame them
none of them I mean back then it's like
[ __ ] that illnesses that we don't even
think about nowadays like you would just
kind of you know shake it off I mean it
killed people yeah they didn't know
anything about sanitation they didn't
know anything about antibiotics they
didn't know anything about that right
there was no criminal justice system
there wasn't any kind of justice you
could be murdered too you know what I
mean governments could change and
massacres could happen all kinds of
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] happen in that world
it was not stable that's what I mean
it's everything but it doesn't sound
like a
time everything goes temporary yeah but
you know what you have to you have to
understand if you look at the history of
mankind that was the normal state of
things the situation we're in now as
modern people is not the norm yeah
the standards have been raised
significantly this is the norm yeah yeah
as well yeah for most of human for most
of human history this is there's people
that robbing you know right so I always
try to [ __ ] make sure because a lot
of modern people me growing up in
different cultures helps me I think try
to keep all you [ __ ] in line we
are in a very privileged situation oh
definitely the poorest of person today
in the Western world and even you talk
about the India to a certain extent in
China the poorest person is living
better than a king did in this era back
in the old days yeah oh yeah yeah so we
have improved substantially that was one
of the funny thing and I think we
mentioned this when we reviewed the the
Dracula BBC miniseries yeah where he did
actually make a point when he came into
the modern day of like 22 that woman's
like kind of crappy house yeah and he
was like talking about how even like the
bigot like the richest wealthiest
noblemen didn't have what didn't have
what that woman had and she was like you
know lower-class she's a low-class woman
but she had refrigeration yeah she had a
refrigeration a TV a TV she had [ __ ]
electronic things yeah she lived [ __ ]
running water and running water in a
clean house and inside baths where the
vacuum cleaner and you know I mean and
the ability to get rid of garbage you
know that's not the way the Angels like
I said back and then we talked about
this on the Lizzie Borden show it's like
as wealthy as they were back then new
shows yeah open in the bowl they shot in
a bowl pooping in the bowl and put it in
the cabin he put it up in a cab and he
ran that [ __ ] bowl until it was full
I guarantee you well yeah because why
would you wanna like you'd want it to be
all like full it's it's kind of like you
know when your dishwasher you don't want
to run it with just like two or three
dishes in there you want to wait till
all of the dishes
and then your how many y'all oh how many
y'all have a ball is [ __ ] in your house
right now lianna's even even poor even
your poor as a [ __ ] even if even
if you're poor as [ __ ]
alright I guarantee you you do not have
a bowl of [ __ ] in your house unless
you're a hoarder there's got to be
something wrong with you you have a
[ __ ] your house because remember
I've seen a couple episodes of Hoarders
where they didn't say [ __ ] where they
were saving their [ __ ] like that jars of
it were bags of it yeah but that is very
rightly considered a mental illness
nowadays yeah how much the norms have
changed just in the past century a
couple of centuries so even if you're a
hood rat up in a hood you were living
like a [ __ ] King compared to what
it's like yeah
life back then I would not want to go
back there not for anyway if I were to
live in that era I would either want to
be a [ __ ] nobleman which I had a
bunch of servants and a capably
spotlessly clean well yeah or I'd be
like Jeremiah [ __ ] Johnson
living out just like live out in the
wilderness out in the wilderness seems
like it would be more sanitary more
sanitary I would think yeah life had
just clean living you cuz even like
noble men like if you lived in a house
like in a city I mean I guess if you
lived in a manor house would be okay but
it would still be full of rats it would
still be full of poop it would still be
like your food would be like full of
flies and stuff like that and maggots
and whatnot yeah they mean they've
excavated old apartments from the Roman
period and they the kitchen and the
[ __ ] was right next to each other so
they ate SH at the same place well I
think we mentioned before they probably
thought oh well it's just convenient
because you eat one you should goes in
one end you only have to go next Dora
yeah their thinking was not like ours
okay which you would think I said and I
think I mentioned it before it's like
you would think that would be a very
obvious thing it's like I really don't
want to like they don't [ __ ] where you
eat I mean that isn't realize all the
[ __ ] bodily functions into one area
of the house is when it's going out
same same thing but it don't matter if
flies land on the [ __ ] and lands on the
food that don't matter
yeah it really didn't seem to occur to
them did it it's all smell that's
another t-shirt it's all it's all yeah I
kinda want to make that shirt but if
somebody hasn't it's all ain't it I'm
not sure this smells good smells good
they probably thought that [ __ ] smelled
[Laughter]
well compared to like probably what they
were eating back they probably did I
don't I saw Roman recipes you know Roman
fast food was to take a mouse and
[ __ ] break its neck dip it and dam
olive oil and before swallow it in the
hole that was their version of fast food
did like weight like rah rah yeah the
[ __ ] room well they were just trying to
get some protein they bred too but well
that makes it better yeah they didn't
really have what we had but a street
vendor might have a whole box a dab like
Anna bait box yeah fill with [ __ ]
alive mice cuz mice are easy to breed
yeah okay and you can get mice anywhere
out of any one of those Deb so what they
would do is they'd sell you a live mouse
and you broke the neck and you would dip
the mouse into a cup of olive oil that
you got from the same guy and then you'd
swallow that because the oil would help
you swallow it and then you would drink
the oil down and then you have a piece
of little loaf of bread or a piece of
bread and you'd eat all that with the
oil they loved olive oil and it might be
Flay well I agree with but they would
swallow a mouse hole yeah with the fur
on it and everything can I say I love
the idea of an ancient Roman food truck
that's just all raw mice yeah but you
can have it like lots of different ways
like you can have a desert mouse where
you can like dip it in dark chocolate
and also you could have like a
south-of-the-border raw mouse or you
could like if it in chili powder the
happiest the Romans have this stuff
called Gerald
it was I'm calling it oil but it was
actually garam and there's been some
recipes of garam you know that has
survived over time it's kind of like
flavored olive oil
it was olive oil with seasonings in it
and I think anchovies
so I don't they thought it tasted great
but it doesn't
I remember reading that recipe and I was
like mesh this probably tastes terrible
so there their concept of what tasted
good was probably pretty [ __ ] up I
said also was in the 50s because they
like put [ __ ] pimento
olives and jello together and everything
had mayonnaise on it and they had salt
but it was expensive only if only rich
people could have solved yeah they had a
lot of little seasonings and stuff but a
lot of the stuff just involved garam
bread and mice I think I'll just stick
that's what y'all think that was the
hamburger of the day yeah damn Massa
bread yeah
rich people probably need that though I
would hope they were eatin like
elephants ang
that's it yeah that's another room in
food truck yeah elephant vets they would
the [ __ ] rich Romans yeah cuz you
know they we have all kinds of lists of
[ __ ] that was ordered for parties and
stuff you know rich people had and
historians recorded what you would
[ __ ] serve a whole elephant you know
something that came out of the Deaf
already impressive I have to admit an
elephant vagine' they they liked they
liked they liked sexual organs evidently
I mean you know who knows how much of
this is true now I kind of wonder if it
was like some ancient Roman writer
little trolling everybody she's like in
two thousand years they're gonna think
they're really well they were changing
everything was about opulence yeah
opulence you know and I guess elephant
vag was some [ __ ] opulent [ __ ]
it could be delicious for all I know
I doubt it people still eat [ __ ] they
eat like you know mountain oysters and
stuff yeah yeah start i don't but some
people do yeah that was long as I
remember well I can see why that would
be that was that was somewhat elephant
couch yeah that was something that was
something an emperor sir yeah I want to
go back in time just for five minutes
would be at that party I was a huge
cooked elephant and it was standing up
and it was they rolled it in standing up
you know I mean and uh and then the part
that actually kind of impressed as me
yeah
like you know what I mean cuz elephants
are big yeah I would be cooking in
didn't say I was gonna say what is they
build an oven big enough to cook a whole
[ __ ] elephant nothing main camera I
think it might've been swiped Oh Gnaeus
I don't remember who it was it wrote
about that [ __ ] made that up so they
were it was things that maybe was a baby
elephant it evidently was stuff that was
coming out of the Coliseum okay because
they have animal hunts in the concert
yeah and I want to know whether or not
they were [ __ ] actually eat any of
those [ __ ] gladiators are being killed
I went it makes you wonder what hey it
wouldn't surprise maybe they serve human
flesh as a delicacy that would surprise
me I was just watching the thing today
where it said that they had actually
found a couple of skeletons and stuff
like that of female gladiators no no
that was that was talked about that was
talked about in in in Roman history yeah
that later on became kind of like a
[ __ ] like a look I would say like I
guess he said I got delicacy watch women
fight each other yeah and it was like
wrestling and regular gladiatorial
combat it was like glue yeah gorgeous
ladies of wrestling except to be
gorgeously yeah flattery knows a lot of
a lot of misconceptions about
gladiatorial combat there were different
kinds of gladiators some of them were
just
prisoners yeah never there to reenact
battles they were there to die okay
because certain people had to die for
these battles but your average real
expensive professional gladiator for the
most part didn't fight to the death they
were told they were handsome
yeah I was gonna say they boot they were
like big drawers for me I would imagine
there were certain Emperor's that
started to come back on the scene going
up that's it we've got to have death
matches yeah because it had been a long
time since somebody had actually been
killed a gladiatorial combat and you
know I mean that they were taking the
spice out of it they became come well
yeah cuz everyone's just kind of like
yeah aim yes become a kind of like
professional boxing we're going out
there fighting and yeah they kind of
have a victory but he didn't actually
kill you cuz even nowadays I kind of
feel like a lot of the reason that
people watch stuff like NASCAR and stuff
even if they still got some [ __ ] crash
yeah and maybe someone will die yeah
well it was like I don't think they want
people to die I'm just saying they'd be
kind of like jazz but they had certain
but to come back and try to bring back
the good old days and part of bringing
back the good old days was like saying
fight to the certain amount of dudes
have to die ticket sales are down
all we really need to like yeah
now creepily this mass baby rave that
was found in Ashkelon is not the only
such mass grave that has been found in
the what was once the Roman world
there was also there's also a place in
England called Hambledon which is in
Buckinghamshire County now in 1912 there
was an archaeologist with yet another
unfortunate name his name was Alfred Cox
and it's [ __ ] spelled like Cox not only
is he not like Co X you know I mean they
were raising roosters yeah support
Alfred Cox which is worse than Ross Voss
I have to say he actually found he was
leading an excavation and Hambledon
which was the site of a former Roman
villa and found the remains
103 individuals 97 of whom were babies
three of them were kids and three were
adults now the same thing applied
because like I said they had found other
cemeteries before another other mass
graves before but there had been like a
wider range in ages
just like in Ashkelon this also appeared
that the babies had all been killed
within the first week of life and that
they had been otherwise healthy so that
they had been killed for some reason
like unknown to them now there had been
speculation that maybe because there was
kind of a roman thing and this is kind
of a common thing and then a lot of
other cultures at the time too that you
know maybe they're all female babies or
most of them were female babies because
a lot of times you know there was kind
of a thing where it's like oh the the
females were not as valuable as the
males and so they would hold on yeah it
would be something like that
I mean they've even found letters like
from the 1st century BCE where you know
a husband is saying to his pregnant wife
you know if it's a boy keep it if it's a
girl discard it or throw it out however
when they did DNA testing on several of
these bodies it was found that actually
now they couldn't get DNA out of all of
them because obviously they're very old
but the ones that they tested were
actually there were some females but
they were more male than female so but
they were all like I said they were all
about a week old or less than a week old
now the weird thing about it is that at
the ashkelon site they're kind of going
on the presumption that well maybe this
was a brothel and maybe these were the
babies of prostitutes and you know
things like that and they just you know
couldn't have them around or whatever
but then again like some other
researchers said you know prostitutes
even in ancient times were very good at
you know avoiding getting pregnant or
they had ways to abort fetuses if they
did get pregnant and they were very good
at that so how would they have just been
so lacks as to like have all of these
babies like because
they presume particularly at the
ashkelon site in Israel it seems like
the babies were like thrown down the
sewer drain you know what I mean like
when they were a particular age so
they're not entirely sure why these
babies were discarded in this fashion
even though they're pretty sure that the
ash that the Ashkelon site was brothel
but they're not entirely sure that
that's why the babies were there why the
babies were discarded the other site in
England I don't think it was related to
a brothel in any way so they're not
really sure what this mass grave might
entail like you said is this just some
kind of like baby dumping ground like
this is where everybody dumped their
babies that they didn't want because
there really doesn't seem to be any
particular reason why like they were all
left in this one particular spot I have
a feeling this prior it was I mean and
there was probably lots of these places
these are just maybe there these are
just the ones now they have found
another one they found one in Thailand
from the same era and they found one
somewhere else - that was from the same
era also I'm sure every little city kind
of had oh this is where the babies go
yeah like that's just like when you're a
teenager everybody knows where you go
Park yeah maybe I [ __ ] up but it's
like everybody knew where the makeout
spot that's priorities the the site in
England though is interesting because
they think from the way that the the
graves are kind of situated that it
looked like the babies were dumped like
in secret which kind of you know goes
along with what we're saying that it's
like that was people going in the middle
of the night and dumping the big donut
[ __ ] there
I'm like left in it leaving it in there
yeah I guess it's like the modern
equivalent of like you remember like
back in the back in the day I'm really
back in the early 20th century up until
maybe about the 50s when it was like
really looked down upon to be like an
unmarried woman with a baby
so some especially if you're a teenager
so like some teenage girls would like
hide the pregnancy and then they would
just go and give birth somewhere and
just
like to leave the baby in a dumpster or
something so maybe this is kind of a
case like that only on a massive scale
yeah I kind of feel like that might be
what's going on so then there's kind of
like a girl
underground about where to go do this
yeah they all know cuz then astral on it
appears that they were all dumped down
because it was a sewer where they found
all of them so there was like a drain
above it presumably yeah I think that
that's they just like thrown is probably
easy to lift up the [ __ ] lid yeah
right so they just that was really worth
throwing them gah can you imagine yeah I
can imagine it I can't - that's horrible
about it yeah like I said it's [ __ ] up
thinking about that's like I you can
understand why they did it and it's like
I said it was a pretty common practice
and I don't think it's probably like you
said it's probably teenage girls that
were getting pregnant out of wedlock
yeah so they just laid low had the kid
do it down that drain that went back to
to doing their daughter like that yeah
cuz I feel like that kind of happened I
mean I know that that even happier
people they haven't changed much yeah I
think that even happened like he even up
until fairly recently in like countries
where abortion was illegal like Ireland
got it going on here Mandy got girls
give me [ __ ] birth in the damn
bathroom stalled at the [ __ ] prom and
throwing this [ __ ] and the damn [ __ ]
wastebasket next to the [ __ ] toilet
that's what I mean there are a few we're
talking I mean there are a few cases of
that right like I said it's probably
just like that like nowadays it seems
like it's a thankfully you know it's
pretty isolated incidents but back then
back then widespread it's bred yeah
because like you said it was probably
like peasant families and they're like
oh here's another one we can't afford
that yeah and she's not married yet and
if she has a kid she'll never get
married so she's gonna throw that one
away
yeah and a dude did it he's a loser
she's not what sure which one it was
yeah cuz she's [ __ ] not you know she's
getting knocked down by three or four of
them yeah you don't know yeah but it was
something like that
there's something very [ __ ] human and
very [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah that's what it's just I think the
thing that freaks people out about it is
that it was just one area where it
seemed like that was the place that you
went it was in the girl underground yeah
they are all telling each other
you know speaking of girl Underground's
well kind of let's talk about low cost
of the poisoner or low cousteau okay so
I kind of love this so as I said now I
don't know if she was technically the
world's first serial killer I kind of
doubt it
but sometimes she is called the first
serial killer at least the first female
serial killer although I guess a more
apt title would be an assassin but I
guess what makes her a serial killers
that she seemed to like be into it like
she seemed to enjoy it and she would do
it even if she wasn't hired to so I
guess that kind of makes her a serial
killer
so they don't actually know much about
her early life she's called Lowe Costa
of Gaul so they figured that she was
probably from Gaul she they think she
probably came from a peasant family um
from the what they call the dark side of
the Alps in what is present-day France
now it wasn't that uncommon for a lot of
villages back then to have a because
they didn't have doctors and [ __ ] like
that really particularly in smaller
villages so you'd have a wise woman who
knew about all the herbs and whatnot and
like what was good for you what was bad
for you and stuff like that so they
figured that lo Costa had probably
learned about various herbs and also
poisons from her barbarian ancestors so
no one knows quite how but she ended up
in Rome by the middle of the first
century CE
and she was apparently so knowledgeable
about poisons and was really into it
like she seemed like that [ __ ]
remember that dude that we did the show
about like Graham young like who was
that's all he cared about was like
reading about poisons like what they did
she seemed a little bit like that this
seemed like her kind of whole reason for
being and she was like super super good
at it so she had like all of these
recipes and stuff like that and she was
apparently the best one and her
reputation kind of grew out of that
so uh so she um ended up I mean she was
super serious about this she had had all
different kind of recipes she had
created all these different kind of
poisons and she knew what they did and
like you know how you could hide them
from various things and stuff so she
even took to testing all of her stuff on
animals probably on relatives to I don't
really know allegedly to make sure that
they worked and she had like extensive
notes about what worked and what did it
so the fact that she was so good at this
her name eventually ended up getting
around and she ended up getting like a
lot of kind of wealthy clientele who
wanted someone bumped off in kind of a
low-key plausible deniability kind of
fashion so uh yeah so she's her she had
all kind of like wealthy clients now she
did actually end up getting arrested a
couple of times for murder
however because she had so many wealthy
and influential clients somebody always
managed to pay her bail and get her out
of there you know what I mean so uh you
know so 54 Cee Lo Costa is contacted by
the very famous Empress Julia Agri Pina
who was the wife and also the niece of
Emperor Claudius Claudius had a son and
heir from his previous marriage to a
woman named Messalina so but Agra Pina
had her own son Nero and she wanted Nero
to be the Emperor but it seemed like
there was [ __ ] in the way Claudius was
in the way and also Claudius's son
Britannicus who was at this point only
thirteen years old was also went away so
Agra Pina decides I'm a higher this
poisoner woman to bump these [ __ ] off
because that's what you did if you heard
like back in the [ __ ] all the [ __ ]
that's what I was saying before it she
seemed like it was technically it was
not legal but it was just it was almost
kind of like accepted you know what I
mean well okay
murder was illegal
yeah but to prove murder means it was
almost nearly impossible by those day in
you know they didn't have [ __ ] any
kind of forensics also the Roman trial
system and their legal system was very
different than what you'd have today
it's like a public forum yeah and you'd
have like a you'd have a prosecute or
yeah yeah I mean who would sit there and
[ __ ] say yeah this person we think
this person did it and then you'd have a
[ __ ] a defense attorney I think it was
called a secure Thor I think is what it
was something fought for you I mean you
know the people in the audience could
could you know could probably [ __ ]
chime in if they know the difference I
mean it's this is unscripted it's all
from memory basically they had an
argument over whether or not you did it
or not yeah [ __ ] huge mass of random
[ __ ] you know I mean who were
totally [ __ ] you know what I mean
totally uneducated and totally unfit to
be a juror is a big they were just kind
of [ __ ] it was kind of like a cop is
kind of like it and they would all vote
whether or not they thought you were
guilty or not it's kind of like a
popularity contest I could do that yeah
if you had good charisma alright you
could get off yeah easily it's like oh
yeah but here but on the other hand you
could be you could be innocent and
[ __ ] be found guilty if you also if
you Doug Lee if you were ugly or
something or they just didn't like it
yeah I so it wasn't I feel like that
happens a little bit nowadays yeah it
really much works but it was worse back
then ugly people are always now
considered yeah the did not is
trustworthy that the quote justice
system unquote it's always gonna be
[ __ ] up no matter what time period
you're talking about because it's humans
and humans are imperfect and there's
corruption involved too if you I mean
that kind of goes along with if you come
from a powerful family and you have
money then [ __ ] that helps a lot look
ya'll y'all [ __ ] need to
understand just look at the damn Epstein
case if you are rich and powerful and
you can afford
powerful attorneys and you got dirt on
[ __ ] powerful men you can do it out
of hell you want you can be found guilty
and you can get out of prison all right
now eventually they got his ass they
killed him everybody knows that that man
didn't kill himself
he had too much dirt on people and he
was gonna [ __ ] roll over and this is
a show we can talk about it you know I
mean then the algorithms aren't gonna
hear me they're not gonna understand I'm
talking about me you understand because
the AI algorithms are listening all
right but know if you're the right
person you can get away with anything
well look at look at Lucca stay here
yeah she poisoned a couple of people and
got away with it because she had rich
friends and clients and stuff like that
who got her off yeah even though
everyone kind of knew she did it yeah
and that's heaven she was known for the
[ __ ] she was known for being a poisoner
and that was kind of the standard in the
Roman era era and if you were a
patrician especially in okay Rome had a
class system the [ __ ] the royal
people were called the royal class are
called the patricians the [ __ ] the
military class were the equestrians
everybody else were just citizens and
then most and then the most of Roman not
citizens really you know the citizens
were people that were born and roam over
certain generations or they were [ __ ]
veterans they could vote but if you were
a wealthy patrician you work on pretty
much above the law
if you were a [ __ ] powerful
equestrian you were pretty much above
the law as long as you weren't [ __ ]
over other equestrians and other
patricians you are gonna be alright and
I and they mostly didn't mess with their
own well I feel like then as now the law
is kind of for the peasants exactly is
to keep you [ __ ] peasants under
goddamn control yeah to keep you from
[ __ ] with the Ridgid yeah that's kind
of what they're for yeah so all right so
um so Agri Pina has hired locust ax to
do her magic and get rid of Emperor
Claudius who was her husband as well
her uncle as I said however Claudius um
you know as well as a lot of room and
Emperor's at this time weren't dummies
and they knew that everyone was getting
poisoned left and right so a lot of them
employed food tasters bodyguards things
like that Claudius actually had a
bodyguard he also had two food tasters
however he was also a big fan of
mushrooms god damn it he loved him some
mushrooms I love me some mushrooms I do
as well yeah it's weird because I didn't
like him when I was a kid but now I just
can't get enough of the [ __ ] they're
really good we should actually get some
of them big old mushroom caps and baby
portobello [ __ ] yeah I used to really
like this Portobello like here we go
talking about for you to get started
billboard a big old portobello panini
take some mushrooms and stuff them
[ __ ] with [ __ ] crab and cheese oh
god damn bean ice okay so okay so what
the plan was what look who stood did
first cuz like I said she was no slouch
herself she had like a whole plan laid
out and apparently agar Pina gave her a
[ __ ] ton of money to work this out so
she made a poison for the bodyguard not
to kill him but to just like make him
sick enough that he wouldn't come to
work that day like it gave him like
really raging shits or something like
that
so then she gave the food tasters a [ __ ]
ton of money like she bribed them it's
like hey how about you not show up to
work today here's all been they were
like okay I can't do so Agri Pina then
buys Claudius a big ol bag of mushrooms
which had a bunch of poison on them that
Luke Cousteau had cooked up so like a
dummy he ate them and then immediately
started having really terrible stomach
pains so anger pina pretends that she's
all concerned and everything she's like
oh my gosh are you sick is it something
you ate here half a feather so you can
throw it up however the feather had been
coded by lacustrine I damn so see she
doesn't miss a [ __ ] child Olson she
doesn't miss a [ __ ] trick wait till
you get to the other edge it's like she
thought of everything so he takes the
feather
and like you tried to use it to throw up
however it had strychnine on it so it
[ __ ] killed him
so Britannicus who was Claudius's son
was still only 13 years old and at this
point since Agri Pina had tricked
Claudius into naming nearer the air Nero
subsequently became a crowned Emperor
and you guys know how well that worked
out however shortly after this happened
Agra Pina acted like a total [ __ ] and
because she didn't want to get busted
because people were suspecting they're
like hey you had Claudius bumped off
like to get nearer to be Emperor we know
so what she did was she threw locust ax
under the bus she basically said that
[ __ ] did it I didn't have anything to
do it I'm just over here completely
innocent you know I just tried to help
him whatever so she gets so Luke Husa
gets thrown in jail and is going to be
executed however while waiting for her
execution she gets sprung out of jail by
Nero himself because Nero apparently had
gotten sick of his mom [ __ ] yes she
killed most of his family so he had
gotten sick of his mom [ __ ] so he
decided to bus look who's - out of jail
and he was kind of afraid - that when
Britannicus got to be of age that he
would challenge him for the throne so he
was like alright well we have to get rid
of Britannicus who like I said remember
is a 13 year old kid so Luke who she
gets out of jail in 55 C E and she was
given not only a general pardon for all
crimes she had committed in the past but
also apparently for all crimes she would
subsequently commit
oh [ __ ] Kart watch that means she I mean
it didn't work out that way but it's
like that's what Prime's in the future
that's what Nero's told her he also gave
her a [ __ ] ton of money and a whole
bunch of land yeah and he named her the
official poisoner of the [ __ ] so you
see how in the open now it was this was
this confirmed is confirmed several
sources have a source it's in several
sources okay so there's a lot of
about Nero there is like the whole thing
about him fiddling while Rome burned
that's not that's not true but it's like
I think Nero actually I think Nero was a
lot better
Emperor though a lot of people think
yeah he killed his own family members
but that isn't that's not necessarily a
bad thing they kind of all did that they
meant yeah they kind of all because for
all we know they were bad maybe they had
to go yeah because these are almost like
Mafia families yeah so you have to work
you have to you have to consider you
know no man was was Nero the better
choice he definitely was into the arts
and some people said that he would be
that you don't get out there and [ __ ]
play the lyre and perform and now some
by some accounts they said he was great
other accounts said that he sucked they
got bored you know or fathers I kind of
would believe that because probably the
people that said he was great we're like
afraid he was gonna do something to them
and they were probably like the rest of
them were just kind of like oh god here
we don't know it was you don't know this
pride just partisan [ __ ] like today with
Trump you know I mean some people say
he's good some people say he's bad just
been and on what side the offense you
were it's difficult to say how he died
was was pretty [ __ ] wild you know I
mean he did [ __ ] order his slave to
kill him because they were they were
[ __ ] coming after him and they did
bury all the complexes that he made his
palace and was ended up they found that
palace later and a lot they found a lot
of cool statues and [ __ ] that he you
know had made in his day after he was
dead I mean you know I mean the [ __ ]
Roman people didn't like him no they
really did not though it's just very
difficult to say we don't know well like
I said we weren't there but let me do it
like I said it seems like most of the
sources that have come down even
contemporary sources they hate it as
God's other problem yeah although I
think Caligula is probably worse yeah
and and i think well Caligula I think
was straight-up crazy yeah I think you
I think he definitely has mental health
Rob's good a lot of a lot of the Roman
emperors were kind of like that there
was always one faction that city was not
awesome
and then another faction that said no
the [ __ ] was garbage so you had
partisanship yeah in Rome you had the
reds and the whites and I don't remember
what else they were called the Optoma
the [ __ ] they had two different
political parties yeah the demagogues
and the [ __ ] optimist Optimum's I
think is what they were called and there
was the best people and the demagogues
yeah it's kind of like Republicans and
Democrats see and the the in the history
that we have is basically tabloid
history will never [ __ ] know we
weren't there well that's what I'm
saying that's him robbers were too great
at [ __ ] rhetoric and a lying so we
just don't know yeah yeah we just don't
know so all right so Nero like I said
has let Lou Costa out of prison and has
given her all these pardons and stuff
and giving her all this money and land
and he's like okay now kill this 13 year
old kid Britannicus who might you know
you served me on the throne one day now
apparently the first poison that look
who's Detroit on him wasn't strong
enough he got really sick but he didn't
die this apparently pissed Nero off so
much that he beat the [ __ ] out of lo
Cousteau with his own hands many sources
say so the next one uh you know cuz he
was like yeah you better get it right
next time and actually killed a [ __ ]
kid so she tries again and this time
listen to this [ __ ] okay so apparently
the Romans and even though Britannicus
was only 13 years old everybody drank
wine even the thirteen-year-old kids
however the Romans tended to drink their
wine mixed with water yeah yeah it's
something new back this up a little bit
nowadays if you were to [ __ ] mix
water with your wine or put ice in your
wine you were you are people what you're
like what the [ __ ] are you doing Romans
did that as a matter of fact if you were
rich rich enough to have ice you
put ice in your wine mm-hmm you watered
that wine down okay that was that was
what they did yeah it was wet gentlemen
very super common there wasn't all this
stuff about aging wine well this all
this wine is [ __ ] twenty years old
hundred years old but they didn't do
that back then wine was just like a
cheap fix it was kind of like a soft
trick and if you mix in to drink it
straight meant you were a low-class
[ __ ]
yeah the drink that [ __ ] straight you
were supposed to water it down yeah and
you were supposed to be eating eels to
rich people eight yields they had little
[ __ ] little Gardens back there with a
little with like a fake pool and on the
outside of the pool the head and four
are in there and they'd let yields go
and breathe eels
out in the backyard did you know that
yeah well yeah a very common even in
Victorian England yeah eels a lot
because they breathe fast and yeah and
and they'd like to that mean I've never
eaten one was I have eaten it I imagine
they probably what do they taste like
they just taste fish its life it's like
fish but it has no fish flavor it's
almost kind of like closer to snake okay
all right so the very light Flay so it's
almost kind of like chicken anymore on
the chicken II know almost no flavor
light flaky almost like egg yolk egg
white okay like an egg white is what
kind of it tastes like and it's just
protein
I had it in it's called you unagi yeah
in in in on top of sushi yeah yeah but
no they love that [ __ ] yeah like I feel
like that was a really common food cuz
like you said they you could breed them
really briefly and you didn't need a lot
of room nah they were very common they
just breed him in a pool back there and
evidently some one of these Nobles got
into some really big [ __ ] because he was
[ __ ] punishing one of his slaves and
through the slave in the damn eel pit in
Ealing lamprey and the lamprey came out
and got him and evidently 88 his ass up
just his ass or all of them need all
that that story went up into the Emperor
and he was like how dare he do not
mistreat these slaves this is a [ __ ]
disrespectful blah blah egg I got
punished I don't know if the [ __ ] guy
got if the guy died from being fit they
were eating lamprey
lamprey I don't imagine those probably
taste very well Scott it that's kind of
an EU I guess they like lampreys a
parasite that's kind of what makes me
think it probably wouldn't taste but
they ate ye'll an lamprey yeah [ __ ]
weird their Romans though yeah like I
said eel doesn't seem all that weird to
me cuz a lot of cultures still eat that
now and you like I said they ate a lot
of them in like Victorian England yeah
yeah well they're steak grow so easily a
member that's what I mean there were
eels actually living in the water system
yeah yeah mate they were everywhere [ __ ]
was everywhere it's like eating a
cockroach like let's eat these goddamn
roaches they're here they're all in
Thailand they do that yeah well you said
they're there but I wouldn't eat that
[ __ ] but in [ __ ] no
well we trim pand those are like the
roaches at the thing yeah she was
gorgeous man I know she was really good
remember when me and you had that shrimp
fest yeah [ __ ] when this storm was
coming Strom was coming over his sands
the [ __ ] price of [ __ ] shrimp
these are the big ass [ __ ] yeah we
thought that hurricane was gonna hit
selling everything all their [ __ ]
shrimp we went down there we got [ __ ]
three five pounds of [ __ ] shrimp and
I cooked that [ __ ] up with [ __ ] corn
on a cob and [ __ ] and white and white
potatoes yeah I had all that [ __ ]
spice in there was a [ __ ] old basin
yeah Oh bassy isn't it boy that [ __ ] we
got a sick of shrimp we were eating so
many shrimp I never get sick of sure I
could eat that every day we're talking
about a protein infusion as pure pros
are like we ate on that for like a week
and built a massive muscle shrimp muscle
shrimp I felt fretless we got a [ __ ]
tear that shrimp up again yeah will do
it's been a while since yeah I mean
we're gonna go on a shrimp binge
since you said shrimp mussel I just
thought of like a little shrimp in the
water with like big ol bleep yeah we're
gonna go on another t-shirt shirt muscle
we're gonna go on we have we haven't
[ __ ] up shrimp lately and we have a
[ __ ] up crab yeah that's true king
crab legs I know
it's been about a year since we [ __ ]
[ __ ] those crabs up I love those but
it's like they're such hard work man
you gotta work for that meat you really
do yeah it's like you gonna crack that
should've got a workfare and you know
it's like you buy the big bag and it's
like $30 or something like that then you
feel like you don't get because most of
the weight is in the in the shell shell
that one time we went down to winn-dixie
and [ __ ] that girl hooked us up
behind the counter remember that she's
like your gear take this yeah that's
really she waited out we got a bunch of
it like this she's like guys take this -
it was like [ __ ] him twice extra yeah
yeah a lot we did it was very good yeah
she's like these teeny little pieces
[Laughter]
yeah it was like I could eat seafood
every day I won [ __ ] seepin yeah yeah
so as we were saying yeah the the high
class Romans used to water down their
wine yeah now obviously lo Costa knew
this she also knew that the food tasters
who checked for poison that was their
job would have tested the wine so what
she ended up doing was that okay so
Britannicus drank some of his wine and
said that the water in it was too hot or
that the wine was too hot so he wanted
some more water put in it to like cool
it off now Lou Cousteau had figured out
that this would happen so she poisoned
the water because she knew that the food
tasters would not be testing the water
they only tested the wine so so
Britannicus drinks the wine with the
poisoned water in it and starts
convulsing right at the table now
Britannicus had epilepsy which a lot at
which everyone knew so when he started
convulsing both near nero said oh he
it's just an epileptic fit don't worry
about it
it's like he'll be fine in a little
while so he just takes him in the other
room and no one does anything about it
because they think he's just having
another epileptic seizure and so they're
all just like sitting there watching it
um I also saw one source that said like
if the kid did die this time around I
also saw one documentary that said that
apparently the kind of poison
locus two used would have left like a
really strange color unlike the boys
skin like on his face and stuff like it
would either turn it like a bluish or
reddish like unnaturally so apparently
the kid was buried like super quick like
before anyone could see him like only
the servants saw him and but they dusted
his face with chalk so like no one would
notice that his skin was a weird color
so they wouldn't suspect so
after this happened Nero gave Luke justö
big estate like I said she was named the
Imperial poisoner he even allowed her to
open I love this open a school for
poisoners damn openly she ran a school
where she trained other people how to
poison is this real or is this okay
apparently like a lot of a lot of
writers wrote about this maybe that was
legal back then so that's what I'm
saying it's like it wasn't a secret yeah
so yeah so Lu Cousteau school where she
trained like a couple other like kind of
famous female poisoners that came along
a little bit later you know so she was
just teaching other people how to make
the [ __ ] I guess I guess you could do
that because you could maintain
plausible deniability you could kind of
say oh she's just an herbalist um yeah
she's making poisons but maybe she's
also making medicines too so it's kind
of like maybe it was like that type of
thing so you could kind of be like you
know I mean like I was listen to this
one podcast where they were talking
about her and they were saying like
maybe it was like a head shop where it's
like you kind of came in and like if you
wanted the illegal [ __ ] you had to like
use the code word and they do it behind
a beaded curtain right here's the point
that is us and maybe it was there like
that but she did actually open a school
and she trained other people how to make
poison like I said before like I said
before Roman Rome did not have a very
intricate legal system yeah to murder
somebody would have been illegal in Rome
but maybe to sell poison wouldn't have
been yeah or maybe to sell poison would
have been legal but to train people to
poison others wouldn't happen right like
you said maybe was a loophole so there
was bunch of loopholes most likely so
yeah the fact that Nero was endorsing
her and he was
Emperor like I don't really think
anybody could do anything about that
yeah and the Romans were also interested
in they love sensationalism you know I
mean yeah they go likes that kind of
[ __ ] so it could be that yeah this is
some [ __ ] bad [ __ ] you know man
it's not really all that more all I miss
about poisoning things but it is kind of
cool not against the law
yeah so let's go ahead and ride with
this all right it'll make a lot of money
yeah people will come in and out of the
door a lot and we'll train all these
people on how to poison anything that's
not the same as killing somebody yeah
train a minute is it that's like a
martial arts you're just like a lot of
martial arts dojo maybe that's how these
things yeah and I mean you're sitting
there you're practicing kung fu' you're
not hitting anybody though yeah so it's
probably something well that's the thing
maybe was just kind of think it's the
wall I'm just teaching people how to
power star but we're not doing it but
we're not killing anybody right yeah
yeah technically that's probably what it
is so she apparently ran a very
successful was had [ __ ] tons of money
very successful business and was
apparently hired by many other clients
might have offed some other people for
Nero later on to you however in 68 C II
famously uh everyone got sick of Nero
[ __ ] and he was condemned to death by
the Senate yeah yeah now apparently lucu
stay had made him a poison suicide kit
that he carried with him most of the
time however when he actually went on
the run the last time he didn't have it
with him so ended up having to like stab
himself err no yes I may have one of his
latest senator so after Nero died and
then evidently he said you know oh wait
today a great artist dies in me [ __ ]
like me and he didn't quote to where she
can you get dude he thought himself as a
rockstar the world is gonna miss me
today a great artist dies awesomeness I
kind of think he was kind of like like
either you know in who I reminds me the
[ __ ] Prime Minister of Canada with
Trudeau
I
there's all the [ __ ] costumes and
[ __ ] I mean he cosplayers he was a guy
like that I think yeah just say it
so although I think I actually I think
Nero cuz I remember I remember hearing
some historians that [ __ ] looked deep
deep into the record and said that
probably what we think of or what we
know of Nero is probably not totally
accurate because they said that they did
see a bunch of economic growth and Rome
was moving ahead economically during his
time so he must have made some good
decisions economically I think he had
personality flaws but they said that he
probably was a pretty good Emperor
that's yeah that's my understanding
but like I said hey he's known as a
douchey [ __ ] that self-promoted
and did a bunch of [ __ ] live a lot
live acts on stage this is a time and
where if you were an actor or a
performer you were basically a hooker
yeah okay you were if you were
respectable you are not supposed to be
on stage doing any kind of [ __ ] music
or any kind of acting Nero was trying to
break that that tradition he would go on
stage and put on hold musical
performances and stuff and he was very
proud of what he did this was evidently
like a huge disgrace for the Roman
Empire they were kind of uptight if you
asked me I don't see any problem with a
dude being an emperor hey I won't play a
tune for you you know what I mean yeah
I don't really see problem a da bird
this is a [ __ ] play a tune if that's
all he was doing Emperor - although if
he was making everybody listen and he
was just boring the [ __ ] I remember me
sucked that would that would kind of
laugh that's that's what's why toniest
was saying okay III kind of suspect that
was probably the truth and he's like hey
don't fall asleep because usually dudes
that are that in-your-face about
everybody has to watch me like
play my latest lyre composition yes
usually they suck because like I said if
they were any good that people would
want to come see them yeah they wouldn't
have to force everybody so I kind of
like suspect that he was making people
because he really sucked and everyone
was just kind of like had to sit there
and smile give you that I'm gonna give
you that but my counter that with the
saying that maybe he was a revolutionary
multimedia emperor
who was trying to put on his own music
videos maybe he wasn't the greatest but
hey he was trying yeah he was trying I
think yeah there's something about what
one of the weird things about Roman
society is that it was it was it was
structured to where the patricians were
supposed to be very honorable noble and
uptight but they weren't allowed to do
any of the cool [ __ ] that average people
like they weren't supposed to be
gladiators they weren't supposed to be
any kind of artists or entertainers that
was for like [ __ ] convicts and
hookers and [ __ ] like that but there was
too much crossover [ __ ] common you
know in the common culture liked that
kind of stuff so there was always this
in Roman society this kind of [ __ ]
urge for the rich people to be kind of
like the poor people yeah always kind of
had guys who were Emperor's trying to
become entertainers you had [ __ ] rich
women trying to turn tricks for fun
yeah because prostitutes were so popular
you know I mean that'd be like the
equivalent of [ __ ] rich girls making
their own porn tapes yeah you know which
that's that's already happened so you
know in American culture we know what
they're talking about there's I just I
just find that find it strange a lot of
these parallels yeah of where the people
at the very top are trying to gain
popularity you know I mean by embracing
I get I don't want to say the culture at
the bottom but the working class culture
they also had a thing for that yeah I
always found that interesting it is kind
of interesting yeah so obviously after
Nero died Lu Cousteau was kind of [ __ ]
his successor was Emperor Galba and he
did not go in so much for this hey let's
poison everybody kind of [ __ ] so he
actually had lucasta arrested and
executed now the very famous story and
probably most most of what most people
know about Lucas is the probably urban
legend that she was executed by being
raped to death by a giraffe what or by
other wild animals yeah that's kind of
like I said when people talk about her I
feel like that's kind of the main thing
that comes up it's kind of like
Catherine the Great and the horse type
of thing it's like whenever somebody
says look who's dead it's like oh she
was great to death by death that is
probably not true where this story came
from was actually from a writer named up
we leus I guess I'm pronouncing that
right in his book the Golden Ass he
actually did have the gold net this
sounds like a porn film it's sorry Nina
Nina Harley yeah it's like I said it's
like in Goldfinger where they like
covered that girl whatever if it was
just her ass then that's look that would
be that boy
but yeah he wrote the book the golden
ass yeah obviously we talked about a
donkey not a human ass yeah um he had a
story about a person or a prisoner or
something like that who was raped to
death by animals or I don't know if it
was specifically by a giraffe or by
other types of wild animals or whatever
however he did not specify that this was
lacustrine and he also apparently made
the claim that this was actually a
fictional story so he wasn't telling it
like it was a true thing that happened
but I do feel like this story kind of
got associated with Lew Cousteau
probably in later years because I feel
like it came up like in kind of an
encyclopedia of serial killers that came
out like you know fairly recently so I
feel like that's kind of where that
association came from but it appears
from another writer back then called
Casius do that Lu Cousteau was probably
just dragged through the streets in
chain
and then just executed in a normal way
like Romans which yes so because they he
named like some other prisoners that
were also you know done the same way so
they feel like probably that I mean rape
to death by a giraffe does sound a lot
splashy ER for sure I said [ __ ] that
the Romans were into but I don't think
and and I mean I do feel like you know I
don't know if this is the case or not
because didn't they say like in some of
the some of the you know shows at the
Coliseum and stuff were let's have women
raped by animals it's like it does
sounds like something they would do but
I don't think that they killed her that
way yeah you know what I mean I think
she was just like I said just like a
regular prisoner she was before
gladiatorial fights one of the things
that the Romans would do they had these
animal hunts yeah guys would go out
there and they'd try to hunt these
[ __ ] exotic animals and by most
accounts of it's pretty damn pitiful
because you'd have a guy out there
trying to hunt [ __ ] like ostriches yeah
I mean and there's or they're out there
trying to [ __ ] hunt lions and the
Lions Lions aren't very violent you know
when you put him in the damn arena okay
there's like I don't sleep yeah well a
lot of times Lions would submit you know
it all hurt me animals outside of their
normal environment aren't very
entertaining if you were if you were try
to put him into a [ __ ] you know I
mean into an arena type situation to eat
people they wouldn't do it they'd run
yeah it'd be like what the [ __ ] am I
doing here yes weird yeah and I don't
like there are even ancient accounts
from [ __ ] like educated people who
saw it they said it's just pitiful boom
yeah animals did not [ __ ] come on the
animals didn't put on a good show
yeah that's why would they the Roman
imagination would [ __ ] you know I
mean it sounded like a good out of like
there's gonna be a good idea they did
have people eaten by [ __ ] leopards
and lions but you usually had a tie to
do to a damn stick yeah you know I mean
and meek the lion attack the guy okay
yeah with the guy the guy I know I dig
you know it's like alright fine I'll eat
em gee
animals are not natural entertainers in
a situation where there's [ __ ]
thousands of people in bleachers watch
well can you imagine what that would be
like for an animal they don't know what
the [ __ ] is going like you know lions
and [ __ ] efforts that they're they're
from the African [ __ ] savannah you
know I mean it in their own pride their
own family you know and and the Lions
that the male lions are not the hunters
the females are yeah you know so the
[ __ ] usually didn't work out I think and
this whole thing about having animals
rape women that's fantasy does something
that a [ __ ] rat Roman made up in his
mind in his mind that's just not gonna
happen buddy into bestiality yeah that's
just not gonna happen
in a [ __ ] in an arena with [ __ ]
thousands of people [ __ ] away it's
not gonna happen do animals that are
giraffes animals will get freaked out
under those conditions and I'm having a
hard time imagining the logistics of a
giraffe raping a woman yeah that's just
something somebody made up because the
giraffes big yeah so you would think
that raph penis is waiting yeah he'll
over the human woman's head yeah and you
would think that that would be like a
quite a spectacle yeah all right now
we're at this yeah and you might be like
Tom with the [ __ ] Tina by giraffe my mom
took care of a dress she had it in her
barn for a while rumba not even [ __ ]
Florida actually it was two or three of
them and zebras I can show you the
pitchers [ __ ] my mom was the one of
the first woman tried it bribed a zebra
yeah I never really could ride what I've
heard that they can't really be dim if
they're too [ __ ] crazy
ya know you're not gonna get a giraffe
to [ __ ] some chickens yeah do it to such
an extent that she dies no I just can't
see that happening no [ __ ] most of
those animals will kill themselves
trying to get away from you yeah when
they were they not a situation that
they're used to being and it's like who
the [ __ ] are all these people looking at
me why am I in this [ __ ] middle of
this [ __ ] that's not where I normally
live why is everyone yelling it I think
the most illegal accounting of any kind
of animal
was right that I remember reading was
they sent a guy down there to [ __ ] a
bunch of [ __ ] ostriches with a bow
and the arrows had big moon crescent
shaped blades and he was shooting heads
off of him and the crowd was booing it
because it would look stupid [ __ ] okay I
can see that also that's chasing down
bears and trying to kill them
now right bears are not as violent as
people think they are a [ __ ] run into
my backyard all time okay it's a big
overgrown dog
well black bears only yeah well even
[ __ ] even [ __ ] Kodiak bears you
can go on YouTube and see videos of guys
to have them in enclosures you know and
petting a damn bear and telling the bear
how much they love the bear and a bear
at least until I don't know but yes now
will a bear kill you [ __ ] right they
will yeah but go watch grizzly man yeah
it's just this [ __ ] up
there's a lot of variation in a bear
bear is a complicated organism it has a
pretty big brain they're [ __ ] huge
there are good Bears and bad bears just
like there are good people are bad
people and you most of the time animals
in an arena type situation would just
[ __ ] of freeze and freak out and they go
on the defense so like I said
understandably yeah yeah and it's not
it's not as though we should they're
used to being in most writings of the
time say that the animal hunt part of
the glaad of the gladiators show was not
very popular yeah because of that that
the animals did not cooperate well yeah
because you can get humans to do what
you want but you can't get image you
can't get animals to do yeah this is all
part of the Roman not to the same the
part of the Roman imagination that an
animal is like a monster and you can
[ __ ] fight it yeah you have to have
an animal that wants to fight you to
make a fight yeah and that's used I mean
generally and like ones you see in shows
nowadays are like trained yeah you know
I mean if you just like throw an animal
in there that you got out of the wild a
rut gonna work out no I don't think so I
tell you what man [ __ ] you know I
mean some of the most scariest push in
the world it goddamn
[ __ ] Egyptian cobra I ran across when
I was in the army and [ __ ] Egypt a
cobra will run from you they don't
[ __ ] most animals whoa yeah they
don't want to get killed
yeah they don't do you're bigger than
them they don't do the thing where they
[ __ ] bow up make the hood I saw one
of them [ __ ] in out in the [ __ ]
Sinai Peninsula you know that's a Cobra
I ran it down and it just continued to
run and it vanished I thought it would
[ __ ] blow up do the [ __ ] Cobra
thing it didn't do it well that's what
happens from watching too many guys
watching too many more risky tikki tavi
too many you know where I got that from
where I got that from Raiders of the
Lost Ark yeah we're [ __ ] you know
yeah EB Falls of the [ __ ] Cobra comes
oh it would do that if you [ __ ] with
it sure yeah but they just run but most
of the time like most of snakes I've
come across they just like they're
scared of you like I said you're bigger
than them yeah that Cobra managed margin
that Cobra outran me easily yeah is that
you cuz you're moving so much look at
that that's weird how did it go like
that okay about to end the show and then
I thought it was gonna go all like
[ __ ] up on me say yeah sorry about all
the blurring I just went into another
dimension alright so that will probably
do it for this rambling discussion of
ancient room hope you guys enjoyed it it
was kind of a discussion of ancient Rome
just a weird [ __ ] that happened back
then the weird [ __ ] that happened back
then among Zen and we've only really
just scraped the surface I just I just
respect me a bunch of other [ __ ] we
could talk about that's what I mean I
just picked out like a few things that I
randomly found that I thought were
interesting you know what I mean cuz now
I have said poisoners I have to polish
back up on my Roman history but [ __ ]
I I [ __ ] used to love that [ __ ] as
kids read about it Fred forever you know
more of it there's new stuff that they
know now you know I mean it was a very
interesting Rome very much like the
United States in certain ways yeah kind
of like the United States and Brazil
combined yeah yeah so anyway let's a
wrap up episode 179 and remember if you
like the show please like share
subscribe
on all your social media tell your
friends and family even your enemies
about us it really does help a lot yeah
share and look contribute we could
always use more patrons that's right if
you would like a translate the show that
would be much appreciated
patrons drive the show we can have a
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
we also have if you go to the blog 13
o'clock podcast WordPress com there is a
button in the sidebar that goes to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation any little bit is much
appreciated that will do it for episode
179 we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]